oh
[Music]
to
oh
[Music]
m
in
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh for
oh
[Music]
is
n
[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
for
oh for
[Music]
oh
I
[Music]
oh
o
[Music]
oh
oh for
[Music]
I don't know
you
[Music]
d
for
[Music]
h
and oh
[Music]
e
a ah
[Music]
for
all
[Music]
is
e e
[Music]
he yeah
he
[Music]
t
o
[Music]
come
is
e
[Music]
[Applause]
e
[Music]
n
is
[Music]
oh
the
[Music]
[Applause]
e e
[Music]
is
a e
[Music]
n
to
[Music]
you oh
n for
[Music]
the
oh
[Music]
is
in
[Music]
oh
e all
[Music]
oh
all
[Music]
n
e
[Music]
the
your
oh
[Music]
is
d
[Music]
oh
around
[Music]
h
oh
[Music]
come
m a
[Music]
oh
I
[Music]
[Laughter]
is
this
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
a
t o
[Music]
see
for
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
oh e
SC
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
the e
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
oh oh
oh
[Music]
come
a
[Music]
oh
oh know
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
[Applause]
d
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
o
I
[Music]
hello we are starting we are starting
okay shall we start
yes let's are we
good oh
yeah oh there's two guests also um thank
you all for joining the culture
conversation
in classroom e um I'm glad um rearrange
the space a little bit so that we do
feel a little bit more um culture
Vibes um I want to um for me it was
really really important to have this
conversation um and I kind of pinged a
and Skyler what a month ago and said I
think this is an important conversation
for us to have um thankfully I agreed um
and was like yes let's have that
conversation in the meantime because
it's very very important to have as many
perspectives on it um as possible and
looking at the culture piece from
different angles um we are also joined
by S and Kim and we're going to look at
kind of different um elements of culture
how the culture of ethereum is evolving
with newcomers how it's evolving
throughout the years and so on but I
want to do a quick intro
um everybody will just intro themselves
I'm Simona I've been in this ecosystem
since the end of
2017 I have gone through um many many
waves of newcomers and waves of energy
levels and waves of um being able to
kind of continue and be motivated to be
in this space because and one of the
main main reasons is because I feel
deeply deeply aligned with the values of
this ecosystem and for me coming into to
this space has been and I always make
this analogy like that really really
deep breath after holding your breath
for a long time and it feels very very
good when you do that and if you think
of that moment we would take like a
really deep breath that's what it felt
like for me coming into the space and it
continues to be that for me um but I
will let my other panelist ists
introduce themselves a do you want to go
yeah um I think it's working it's
working it's working okay uh hello
everyone um I'm a miuchi from the e
Foundation um so this
was more
spontaneous um program that we we try
not to discuss too much in advance so
that we can include other people in the
so we can quit the uh the vibe that
we're including other people to the
conversation so just having a
conversation and I appreciate Simona
suggesting um one of the thing that I
recognize this time of Deon is there
seem to be uh more people have this
desire to to talk about this right like
I I'm always
um uh swamp with so many different
things and I often like have to react to
the different things but this the
hearing the desire of having a
conversation about culture is um not
necessarily always a good thing
but well because people feel like
something is wrong or this something
important is lacking or something we're
losing something or so that I I what I'm
doing try trying to do here is really
trying to listen mostly um and then yeah
if if I have anything that I can share
from my perspective I'm happy to so that
was that that's my intention here but
thanks for having
me uh hi everyone my name is SII I've
been in this space for last 12 years uh
I first started before ethereum time
there is no eam I had to use a Bitcoin
uh uh building Bitcoin SMS wallet so
people who doesn't have internet can
send receive Bitcoin or money on the
text message and then later I buil the
did system in Korea and after building
um all this product looking back to the
ecosystem wow there's so many other
great Builder I don't probably need to
build anymore and I started looking what
is needed in the ecosystem and was
actually the human layer that's not
there so I start like d and my
background is a social works I love
human I love helping people I love
creating public goods so uh I went back
looking at the ecosystem what's missing
and how can I start it and then of found
outs and Community governance organizing
in so many different way but right now I
am I think experimenting let's put it
that way cuz our ecosystem is still very
very young uh what is actually working
and where is the pain point point of uh
building community and then Building
stories building narrative and cohesive
narrative and that all related to
culture I think that's why I'm invited
today uh I'm happy to discuss further
more uh and happy to be
here hi my name is Kim I work with
funding the commons and I've been um
exposed to web 3 for about 9 months
anyone else newer than me in the
room so there doesn't usually happen I
feel like I've been really really new so
hi welcome you're in it with me um and I
was very excited to participate to this
conversation and to be invited and that
is also a testament to this culture
there are very few industries that would
put a newcomer on stage uh to hear what
they have to think about their
experience on
boarding um and how Industries on board
is also a big part of their um success
or failure so it's just been uh really
significant for me to be invited into
this conversation and I'm happy to
contribute with beginner's mind um my
background is in Communications um and
I've spent the past decade and a half
helping uh Brands institutions and
personalities to express their culture
and to make culture um I'm now working
with funding the commons uh on the
public goods side and uh it's been
interesting because it is uh a bit of a
Gateway for people who haven't yet
experienced exped um what we do and so
I'm hoping to build more uh of those
bridges awesome thank you okay so what
do we feel um in what ways do we feel
the culture of ethereum has contributed
to its
success and what's unique about it if
you have like a thing that's very very
unique whomever wants to take
that maybe I can it might be okay this
is conversation by the way guys it's not
a panel we should that way and this is
very intimate space so I was going to be
very open uh and vulnerable most of all
for me ethereum has been just no longer
technology and it has become a lifestyle
and uh when I say lifestyle you don't
actually design your lifestyle around
technology I mean could be these days
but it's it's more like a value it's
more like a philosophy it's more about
the people so it all come down to a
people that you met at the ethereum
ecosystem that has actually
significantly contributed to the
ecosystem because uh the ecosystem is
again it's not just like a a code is
bringing people uh it has so many
different value that is creating uh uh
the momentum of for people to be uh how
can I say align with that brand or that
the image of etherum so when you are
when you say like okay I'm part of
etherum community that there is a sense
of like a
proudness uh
integrity and also I'm not compromising
because I know there is not just me but
a bunch of army of Community member
building something that is pretty much
align and here to create some long
positive impact for Humanity so that's
what
um I think ethereum's value is really
hard to put it in words but there's a
feeling the energy that has created and
that's what our Builders to be here the
new people come they're like oh this
feels very different and uh yesterday
like the one of the MC guy I post on the
Twitter I've been seeing so many
different conferences but it in deathcon
in like huge stage people maintain quiet
and they wait and they're not making
noise so they're very genuine
and really integral people here in this
community uh I mean being quiet is a one
example but you you all feel that's why
I think etherum is very very different
and the reason why etherum is also
different is this is not a company you
know this is a community so it's really
hard to put again the CES there's no
like uh this is Code of Conduct if you
don't do this you kicked out you know
it's like there is so many different
analogy that I use for like a nature
analogy of infinite Garden you cannot
kick out like butterfly coming in yeah
it's not like a house that is closed off
it's always open so more work clearly
more work but because of that openness I
think people just stay calm keep
building and not feeling like I have to
meet somewhere but like I'm doing
because I am in this soil so that's the
power uh over3 in my opinion
yeah um I will give you maybe my
personal story um before eum uh I I also
joined the industry officiary around
2013 um and this that was before etherum
time um and then I was at a a a
business and one name
where but one of the uh one of the
biggest exchanges um and I was about to
the space um the reason why is that um
well my from the very
beginning I think my my everything is is
well connected what I do in my life is
um from the very beginning my interest
was really whether this Tech can help um
create better humanity and um if if
anything I do is part of making just
rich people or richer and um so I was
ready to
quit and um and I went to my first Devon
experience was Devon 2 in
Shanghai um and I think the one Devon 2
was actually a bit different vibe right
uh for people you who went there could
understand but still there was this part
of this this event that didn't look like
event and then this nerdiness and this
and like we're pretty disorganized even
Decon 3 was pretty
disorganized
but I liked it I like the vibe oh this
is something I've never seen in this
blockchain or crypto back then like a
lot of Bitcoin event happening so it was
very different um and the reason why I
decided to help when they asked me to
help e was really that that I saw the
soul there um
and I always say this if I if if I see
this is not going toward the direction
that I was hoping and then I'm always
ready to quit because that's the like a
is that that the you know one one method
to get to the the world that I want to
see um and that but that is very
important and so that's why I I'm glad
that you guys are able to to see see
that through Devcon because Devcon is
it's not a an event for me it's it's an
experience we're trying to provide an
experience and how do we so every single
decision hopefully uh people are feeling
it um little piece of like how design of
this logo and everything that we discuss
uh the team discuss like I'm not
involved in everything but yeah this the
design is is very important so I think
in terms of the importance of the
culture culture to me is base of
everything and um so that how do we when
when a new comer comes to this
experience and the deor is just one one
one method uh I use the term Monastery
if acting as a monastery like Deon can
be one
Monastery you come here and then you
learn uh you you we not just learning
the technology because you can learn the
technology uh well how to Cote online
right but being together in
person what are you getting and then
that's the that's the piece of thought
that I we want everyone to experience
and that's why if culture is not here
with Devon there's no point of doing
this yeah so that's that's I think it's
how much culture is important I love
that
Kim some things are coming up for me
when you ask the a question about this
idea of success right you asked um what
in the values um of ethereum of actually
because we were speaking earlier about
individual uh metrics of success and
indiv sucess and individual
flourishing um and I'd love to talk
about that a little bit as a like what
does success look like and how have you
been thinking about
this so um just looping into um what
both I and S said and with my own
thoughts on this I I genuinely feel and
continuing from that metaphor of that
deep breath that you feel and I'm I'm
sure a lot of us feel that it is that
freedom that you immediately feel as an
individual the freedom to be exposed to
so many possibilities that I think the
world as it is and it has been for
generation has felt very very
constricted this isn't a company it is a
space it's a feeling it's a soul it when
you were saying about Soul it reminded
me of that movie called 21 GRS does
anybody know that and it's like when the
soul leaves the body it's lighter by 21
GRS and going into it from that Soul
perspective it's there's that resonance
that happens and I think for me the
measure of success there is do I feel
I'm in a space where I can really really
live up to my true potential in terms of
creativity in terms of where can I put
my energy that is far greater than being
a quota achieving a whatever Revenue
achieving whatever client that's a
billion dollars whatever whatever right
it's they're not small things that we're
talking about here and really I think
it's that kind of resonance that happens
when you feel you are also in the
presence of other people feeling the
same thing I think that's what amplifies
right it's almost like a room with
really good Acoustics and you're like
you have a desire to to do more you have
higher goals and ideals and for
self-actualization and for having a
purpose and then you join others who are
the same and they don't even have to say
it you just feel it and I think that for
me is what has been so successful about
ethereum in particular me I mean this is
the space that i' I've spend most of um
my time in but that's what it is for
me I love what you said about um being
able to reach your full potential I
think a lot of it is um the amount of
creativity you can access when you are
in a space that makes you feel like you
can activate as many parts of yourself
as possible is pretty magical and that's
been my experience so far of finding a
lot of openness to being able to
contribute to connect people in ways
they hadn't been connected before um and
feeling also a bit like a a tourist you
know when you visit a new country and uh
then you meet a few locals and you begin
to say oh I like it here oh I like this
I like that um it's not like I was told
what it would be like I had no idea but
little by little I was like I could move
here I could live here and that's been
the the feeling of of my onboarding
because nothing is spelled out that's
one of the difficulties
also um and um there are some things
that are
Universal um that is true and there are
some things that make me feel like I was
also visiting a country that had all of
these different Landscapes and I was
like oh there's the mountain side
there's the Riverside there's this
side's really hot this side's really
chill this side uh activates me so um
also trying to understand the the
landscape and its complexity and then
what makes everyone the same and I'm
finding it's actually quite a a solid
list of values that um are keeping
things together you talked earlier about
um how much the space has evolved from
your perspect
perspective um and I'd love to go back
to that a little bit cuz I can't talk to
to that piece and I'd love also to hear
a little bit from you about what makes
um people uh similar in in their values
what are those Universal values have
they ever been made
explicit this openness to the point
where some of us could feel a little bit
uncomfortable right but it's like if you
didn't grow up with that very open
culture but still like like a push you
to be very open and vulnerable um like
also as
sitting on the same ground feeling you
know there's no like a
big boss I mean I hope like there some
is foundation people here I hope like
I don't I don't like I don't I never
enjoy being the boss type and then I'm
not trying to be the boss but uh just
trying to be a leader instead but um so
yeah definitely like we it's it has to
be we often say this in in
technology the
cation open source and open
participation permissionless right um
and then those we see that in in people
too it's it's and so that's why we can
proudly say we mean it when we say the
centralization we we mean it right when
we
see uh this most Global de gone this
this time like um 100 people from 145
countries are here yeah so that is um
definitely the important um even having
this cultural
conversation uh spontaneously it's it's
a so there's no like EF deciding
everything like um there are a lot of
Grassroots opinions and um um requests
or cleansing mechanism like see we it's
like really like nature so eum does make
mistakes cultur too I think that's like
it's my my personal view so don't take
it as as official EF VI please but you
know but but but then there's always
learning and then after that it gets
stronger and we we we've seen it and I
think that's very powerful yeah if I can
add a little bit echoing all what you
guys share I think when I mentioned
earlier like a lifestyle is like really
the life design right
and the universal value the all human
has is actually the freedom and in Hope
and happiness they want to be healthy
and happy eventually if they can I think
that's what the universal value is and
in the history of hum uh there are a lot
of you know happiness has been always a
topic and you know like everybody talks
about happiness but happiness doesn't
just come with the feeling of happiness
there is a yes content uh but physically
you want to be healthy mentally you want
to be healthy emotionally you want to be
healthy but financially you want to be
healthy as well and I think what
ethereum is is actually make us to do
and actually giving us the capacity to
do is not just talking about this
invisible value but also very much a
tangible value and at least the
opportunity for us to play with those
practicality as well as value cuz in the
normal society
if you want to go for your happiness you
have to compromise it you know you like
okay if you do this like all good things
about the world and humanity and you
poor that's like a common common like um
agrm and you never be rich by doing good
right and so a lot of people like oh you
know what you you're doing good thing
but you're poor and you not poor but
like you don't have enough resource you
we always have to go fetch resources and
we always have to fight and play in the
very limited resource place and what
ethereum does and what programmable
money what smart contract does is
actually giving us opportunity to design
incentive and then design contribution
and then measure that in a human way I
know we are not there yet I'm not saying
if you're new to we are not there so
don't expect okay you know what let me
go find those tools it's not there
that's why we are having this
conversation plus uh so
if we get there we if we having more
conversation like this what our
community member and Humanity actually
wants is happiness and healthy and
greater life with a freedom and
technology has to be part of it is
inevitable and if we have to choose one
technology or two technology that align
with our Humanity value and our human
value that actually lead us to where we
want to be I think ethereum is what it
is now and I'm not also saying U maybe
on poopular opinion
ethereum is the only solution it might
be something else but right now there's
no other solution than ethereum so
that's why I am personally here and once
we keep bringing this human layer
conversation cultural conversation
really communicating the de real value
that the universal value that we can
align with other humans that is outside
of crypto then people will start to get
it but if we talk about like technology
too much and smart contract and coding
it doesn't actually get their heart when
they we don't get their heart people not
changing it's only remain here and it's
going to vaporate it right so the
universal value I really value that
question so we we should keep talking
about freedom but not just like let's
let us free not like fighting but like
how can we create a real Freedom
including all other
Freedom physical emotional mental but
financial and also resource and there is
so many different layer that we can all
redefine what resource mean it's not
just a money but like time energy
relationship and like so many different
thing I think ethereum technology could
make us get there so that's why I think
the relevance the with the universal
value of human and ethereum comes
together uh and still again saying a lot
work to be done but that's what it is
for me you know what's super interesting
as um we've been chatting and actually
it's the
permissionless or like that element of
it that is probably the piece that is
the most interesting
because in a way there's two sides to
this in a way everywhere else like if
you're in the real world or like in the
traditional
world if you want to do something or to
create something you almost feel like
you have to ask permission to do
something whether you're in a
corporation you have to get something
approved and have to get the budget to
do it so on and so forth there's no
there's not that agency of like I don't
need permission I can just go and do
something and I think the speed of
execution and that's why it's so
exciting for a lot of people the speed
of execution from idea to
something existing is very very fast
and at the same time we've also as
humans have for Generations
been taught to ask for permission no you
have no agency no you have to do things
like this and you have to do it like
this otherwise you don't get money
otherwise you don't get status otherwise
you don't get this this this so always
ask for permission know your
place and I think for a lot of Us coming
in and for a lot of people coming into
this ecosystem
it's almost an
unlearning of that asking for permission
and not believing that you have the
power to do things and I think that's a
really interesting thing again CU we're
talking new generations of newcomers
coming in and so on because it's
permissionless so you can come in do
whatever uh Etc but it's that ability to
unlearn the asking for permission and
what does that unlock for you like what
are you going to do at the same time
though this leads me to uh the
conversation about New Waves of people
coming in and new Adoption and so on how
do we integrate these New Perspectives
and new values and sometimes
extractive
behaviors into these very pure and
wonderful and energizing values that we
have cuz when we were 500 people or a
thousand people it was hell of a lot
easier how do we integrate those into
this evolving kind of culture piece this
is my this is genuinely one of the
reasons why I was like I want to have
this
conversation
thoughts um you know the word uh the the
the line infinite Garden this um
actually my motivation was the same um
in
2020 end of 2020 I think uh when I first
uh it's not even introduced it's more
like I wrote this you know I I write
email to everyone at thether Foundation
end of the year um and then that year it
was during covid and I had more time to
you know pause and reflect reflect
and I felt the like eum was I mean we
felt many times eum was growing growing
growing but that year I felt maybe
because I had more time to reflect I
felt that okay it is actually growing
quickly right um not not with the hype
that year I felt like like it was
actually
going
um and then intuitively I thought that
um
the need of something whatever something
to
to for us to review but also
um like maybe for myself for myself what
is that what is that about
etherum um that that draws me or that
drives this this this technology to to
the next to to the better humanity and
then and then the reason why
I decided to you know like I introduce
that that infinite games is like uh from
the finite infinite games idea is that
it was
if infinite players and infinite games
was was something that I felt I felt
special about
eum a a group of people um like you said
originary it was it was a lot smaller
right but everyone seem to be really um
building something
together for the purpose of like doing
this together not really for one of them
to win and that was very special that
was very special even back then when it
him was W um
so yeah this this not about someone
winning but we are doing this together
right it's and that's why we call it
community not a company
is that was that was my motivation and
it kind of evolved into like other
people just started to discuss about
this um and then we we I needed it
needed that and but it's not something I
invented it small like it was there in
eum and I just wanted to remind everyone
yeah so you asked also about
um the kinds of things that could be put
into into place it's been interesting
for me the entry point was through
funding the commons which is um focusing
the conversation on how do you support
um builders in the ecosystem and we have
you know different formats so you have
conferences that feel very open and then
there are more technical formats like
residencies or hackathons and within the
process of discovering how the
programming was curated I began to
realize that um there were some themes
or verticals that um were an easier
access point and so it's been fun to
meet people who are these Bridges
whether they're working on um climate
projects or um real world use cases you
know to figure out how um to play with
the mechanisms in certain parts of the
world where they're most relevant most
urgently needed and um when they talked
to me about projects it was all in plain
language and that was really reassuring
to enter the space and to say what do
you do oh these people who today cannot
use money are able to pay each other
like okay I get that um it required very
little explanation and it was all very
powerful and so I'm wondering if perhaps
part of this equation is also how do we
allow people to enter through some of
these um illustrative stories and we've
talked a lot um in a few few different
uh settings this week at least the
sessions I was attending about
storytelling and needing to be able to
support those doing great work in in
telling the stories in plain terms and
then also finding the organizations that
we can partner with that straddle
different worlds and that can do that
work for us so um the humanitarian
sector for instance is in dire need of
reinvention we can help um and so who
are the individuals who behave in more
permissionless ways in there and how do
we onboard them um because there are
those personalities also outside I used
to always get in trouble in the
corporate world for not asking for
permission I was always asking for
forgiveness which they say it works it
doesn't um and um it made things
difficult sometimes for me working with
a lot of cross functional teams and and
all of a sudden I'm in a space where
that's not a problem anymore and maybe
that's the breath you were talking
about maybe following
that to be frank if you're new to
ethereum new to any of the crypto
especially in ethereum space it's really
hard to navigate as a newcomer
especially you are not attached to the
organizations or some sort of mission or
initiative you just learn about ethereum
and then genuinely interested in and
like oh okay I want to meet somebody I
want to navigate this space I want to
contribute more and
it's not like people actually go to uh
etherum Foundation website and read
although there is a lot of information
for etherum is is it's really hard to
navigate and a lot of people who also
building individually and contributing
to the ethereum uh as a builder they
don't actually have a community around
them yeah we we just was hanging out
with the African Builders just this
morning and I know some of them they've
been building for like 5 years and they
never been to conference before they
only have four people online friend that
they talk talk and that they just keep
contributing and they're amazing right
and and then these people like they
never actually physically experienced
actually physically experienced ethereum
in person there's are many reason why
they couldn't and then this time they
actually made a lot of effort to be here
even at Devcon uh but there is so many
people who are not here in the The Ether
Community is not just 12,000 people
right there's a huge much more and um
so when people coming to the crypto as
much as we want people to join and
understand ethereum it's really hard to
navigate because there's not enough
instruction is not a bad thing that
that's a nature when you when you go to
the forest when you go to the wild
forest there's a no sign whatsoever you
just like navigate yourself but when
they when they go to for example like
other um token like salana for example
it's a company so it's a very direct
like okay you got this you got this you
got this we have a team we have a head
of country everywhere so they doing
their thing right so they doing their
job on boarding people everything like
so streamlined so people feel like oh
this is like a way easier better on
booting than ethereum but they are they
don't even know they're compromising
what they're compromising because they
don't know about the history of ethereum
so that's why the storytelling point is
really extremely important telling what
ethereum is and then what the history is
and the story form and they actually get
to their heart space and because of that
ethereum space is as much as it's open
but it's also not for everybody right
now because not everybody can align with
that so they have to actually be that
special human that is autonomous that
has a capacity to actually face the
conflict and people who are good at
communication and have a mission and
have a positive energy and hope around
it and don't those people are not many I
mean they hopefully many so it comes
down to and especially in Asia the
recently we started this community
called Pagoda and the how we started is
very beautiful and it the everybody who
was there invited to the Gathering first
and they didn't know what is the out
that they showed up only Asian 50 people
from 14 different country actually
preparing dcon early this year and we
share what the dreaming Asia looked like
with ethereum not for ethereum but with
ethereum share everybody share their
Vision everybody share their Vision we
capture every words of it and we create
the value system and what we want to do
together and then I think the there is a
way that you can way of a creating
Community not to down uh and I think
it's possible I'm happy to share the
Playbook of it but anyway at the end
what come out is actually what's really
important for us is not about technology
it's about
we being better person and ethereum is a
community helping us to be better person
as other peoples are there who are
like-minded so we come up with a concept
of a protocol of being so which is like
a practice of it a meditation writing
whatever you want to do but like how can
we be better person who is equipped to
serve decentralized ecosystem and serve
a value of ethereum like Integrity of it
for example Integrity long-term view
stewardship this is something that we
don't we didn't learn from school so you
have to learn but not alone but in the
community so that's what ethereum has so
that's how you can actually inviting
people by uh really um identifying those
people who are ready first and then show
them it's it's almost like um I don't
want to say this but it's almost like a
the church message you know when you go
to the church people say you you should
you leave the you leave by example you
leave by example otherwise people you
say something it's very valuable but you
act like and then people would not
go to whatever Community you're in so it
actually the personal tration and I take
ethereum as a really the training course
and the training Community for better
human that makes sense but see here's
the thing though the the what you
created with pagota was and this is
coming back to how do we have this
almost like initiation into the culture
you need the spaces to exist because a
lot of people may come across things not
at an event not surrounded by people who
are you know value aligned etc etc and
there is there are these entry points
that are definitely a lot more conducive
to alignment and that kind of like deep
breath that you are with the people who
are you know aligned in terms of values
with you whereas if you read some
stories in the press or have some sort
of friend who got rugged or have some
sort of random meme coin
situation you might not get to the space
where you're able to actually tap into
this beautiful
substance and so I think here's the
challenge or what do we need to do to
ensure that these spaces are open or
opening up for people to be able to tap
in
the right path or have that initiation
so that they don't get disillusioned and
go oh my God yeah no this is a casino
this right these spaces
are the gate way the port whatever you
want to call it but everything that
we've just discussed is around these
things Devcon pagota funding the commons
when I used to do shelling point you see
that like oh yes this is great this is
actually much much much higher than
financial incentive how can I get rich
quick but we do have that aspect to it
how do we make sure that the Beautiful
Soul stuff
does not
get hijacked overshadowed
over whatever by
this
financial incentive aspect of it CU
again we have seen a lot of waves of
people who come in for that very
specific motivation and that's totally
fine that's what thing that is part of
the
multifaceted ways that we also want to
grow as humans like the fin is a reality
but not the reality of scarcity of
extraction of all of this how how I
would quickly say I think we need
definitely need more use cases really
show people what's possible and they can
still actually be feel safe financially
by doing the work that they needs to be
doing and I'm I'm not talking about we
we cannot actually completely ignore the
financial piece right we have to find a
way that we can actually find peace for
that and the the peace the bridge is not
about one or the other it's like how can
this be Blended really well the blending
experience that needs to be exper
experimented more in the space CU right
now it's so divided you either Vision
person or you are like money person and
I don't think they are in initially
different they all looking for the same
thing which is like the happiness and
freedom and all that and I think there
is a way that we can weave that thing
but we don't we can not just speak them
oh no that's not true and then so so is
the other way we have to show them
what's possible and I think we are not
having enough experiment or use cases of
showing that bridge gapping so that's
remember yesterday though um it was um
kind of my favorite statement someone in
the room we were in um said uh it's not
there people say there are no use cases
that's not true there are use cases
we're not really providing ways to find
them right um and then I I was having
this like a blackfast conversation with
our next perum fellows this morning one
of the fellows um Karam he is from Syria
you know he's been um working on doing
research on how to how to use this this
technology to help people in the same
situation he grew up in Syria uh was in
a jail for a while because he was trying
to go against the government
and in that conversation somehow this um
next fellow
conversation small room right like we
normally have people who are already
kind of in the same type type of you
know who are aware of these things but
some one person somehow um well I didn't
know until he told me this morning this
guy was actually just uh somehow like
like just working on this meme coin
person and
somehow I don't think it's accident
intense
conversations and it opened his eyes oh
my gosh I've been I just now now I just
realized that I've been working
on this you know
random stuff like thing but until he
because if he all like you're right
right all meme coins he just would think
that's that's the word that I mean but
that was that
awareness was
was when I heard that this morning oh
wow you just Open the Eyes of someone
who was we we someone else um else um so
I think we need to create more of that
opportunities and you can have one guy
talking about one guy from Syria and
then everyone else is are from me is
important from the Deon team's pers
perspective we are we are trying to
design that in the way that how do we
make more of that conversation happen
right at least like okay you're not you
can't really talk in Devcon you can't
really talk about the price I don't know
if everyone is following
but but that's that's that's kind of
like but in the way that um think also
the beauty of e is like we can kick
someone out we're not we don't we
shouldn't right like if we think like oh
that guy is definitely working on
something wrong I'm not going to say hey
you're not part of e just go away it's
it's I think that that this this is the
community we also are open to have
conversation with anyone and then give
them opportunity to learn or wake up and
uh as long as they're willing to if and
then if they don't
have um curiosity to learn and then they
will naturally go away unfortunately we
can we we don't have PL uh energy
to educate every single person in the
world but our priority is starting with
curiosity C curious on U but how we make
them curious so so that's we need the
intention we need the
design um I always push the team
I don't like quick and easy solution
idea like we need to work for even if
something looks very funny and goofy but
we we we like what's the intention
what's the intention like we yeah so
that's um we yeah but then again like
the challenges like you said it's it's
it's it's growing and also we have this
philosophy of subtraction yeah
um and then having that philosophy at
the same time like I said in the opening
that doesn't mean we do
less we we invite others to share values
together that's that has to be same way
but it's definitely harder way than us
telling hey this is what what you should
do and you go out you you can come in
you go out but if we do that e would
lose lose that that Soul too so we are
going to always have to choose the
harder way so versus like not dictate no
invite wither even if someone like we
feel like oh that's like that's out of
our culture right so we need the
tolerance but at the same time it's not
like just being quiet doing nothing yeah
yeah okay um I kind of want to open it
up to some
questions who has thoughts or not even
questions any
thoughts
oh
live yeah do we have a microphone just
to have floating no okay let's share so
act thank you there was the security
problem disclosed inc2 standard in 2017
theum Foundation finalized the standard
knowing that there is a security issue
reported no process for disclosing
security problems in eips is implemented
in ethereum today 10 years after its
main net release in 2023 Fabian Vell the
creator of rc20 standard who is no
longer working for eum foundation
confirmed that the design of erc20
contains the security pro the
impossibility of handling transfer
errors this issue is still not fixed and
not publicly announced by etherum
Foundation as a result users lost 15
millions of dollars worth of ec20 tokens
since 2017 do you think that this is a
reasonable price that we ethereum users
need to pay for ethereum not having a
process for dealing with security
disclosures in eips 10 years after his
main net
release
yes it isn't that was a very Stern
delivery I kind of missed half of that
question
personally um
I couldn't I appreciate you having that
on video and you clearly want to make a
statement um I think again it may not be
relevant for this panel um I would love
to hear culture based
yes speak sure
um maybe they won't hear it for the
camera that's why okay um so great panel
thank you for sharing your thoughts I
have been thinking a lot about
um as we're trying to cultivate
something how do we also answer the hard
questions people have for us how do we
also like
confront um perception and not be afraid
to go to the hard places and I think
that there's you know as I've
experienced my first conference like
there's a tendency to keep it light not
saying this panel but tendency to keep
it light and not really be like how are
we like actually contending with the
fact that people think this is a scam or
the fact that people hate
us how can we take people to the hard
conversation to be honest I think
conference like this is extremely hard
place to take people go deep uh maybe
you can find like a like a smaller
corner
and
intentionally um bringing people
together to solve it I think intention
is really the half of the conversation
in my opinion um I would love to know
what the hard conversation you might
think maybe we can chat after this uh
but also one thing that we can do in the
etherum community is like really um uh
understanding how to create a safe space
and how to create a space for the deeper
and hot conversation uh I think we can
do it yeah and quickly to your point I
think um this is one of the things that
um like you said with uh people hating
crypto and so on and so on that does
take a allll um having again being in
this ecosystem and maintaining that
energy to continue building whilst
people are like NOP still not convinced
still a scam still like it's draining
it's very very draining and I think a
lot of people who maybe were around in
the beginning and did put a lot of
energy and a lot of effort there's a lot
of people who have like taken a step
back or left or just to recuperate and
like get back to a you know a nervous
system regulated nervous system Dynamic
and that opens up a whole different
conversation but it's exhausting and I
think to your point and having these
conversations where it is a safe space
to kind of support each other through
that because a lot of us are having
those experiences yet we don't
necessarily share that to your point
keeping it you know we see each other
for a short period of time and we want
to keep it light because it's great to
see each other right and so but having
those safe spaces for that is is
definitely
important yes thank
you I think is it is it yes
um so I've been traveling with my
partner for the past two or three years
um my first defcom was in Mota and I
realized that a lot of the energy is
very much directed up here which you
guys also mentioned um how do you think
um that someone's personal well-being
directly reflects to what we are
building in the ecosystem I'm here um
working with different popups cities and
running Wellness track so really opening
this more intimate spaces through
ceremony through rituals to deepen and
like kind of weave in the culture but I
I'm looking at it from an outside but
also stepping in now in terms of like
okay we're creating decentralized
governance different Dows different
protocols um popup cities these
conference and a whole currency how can
we also in a way rewrite the way that we
operate around the work culture and I
believe that the IQ is there um we know
what we have to do but how can we fully
embody it in order for the energy to
fully flow and for our outcome or
because I'm seeing people are building
amazing things with the energy up here
being in fight ORF flight with a very
deregulated nervous system so how can we
in a way rewrite or like move the
culture a little bit more towards
well-being
and see what the results of that is and
how can we measure it yep okay this is
like my favorite
subject um I have this tweet that I
tweeted last year which is you know
what's going to get us from web 2 to web
3 is therapy and I speak from personal
experience um I burnt myself out at the
end of 2022 I in Bogata at Devcon I had
just finished shelling Point um it was
incredibly stressful and somebody at
Defcon came up to me and like Simona
what are you excited about in 2023 and I
went
nothing so the poor person just like
slowly stepped away lest I harm them um
and that I was like oh this is not good
at all and so and so then I had to quit
pretty much everything that I was doing
and really go into therapy and go damn I
think I'm addicted to stress okay where
does that come from okay okay maybe I
need to have some naps maybe I need to
like again make sure that I operate from
a regulated nervous system because if
you are in a stress constant stress
you're not going to you're going to
really let's say limit your ability to
participate in this and actually tap
into those higher values and higher
intentions that we keep talking about
cuz if you're in stress mode you're only
going to think of your base needs and so
with that in mind
I I have this um thing that I've been
talking about where we potentially have
a human protocol running alongside the
technical ones right where the focus is
on the humans where we have boundaries
in place in terms of work hours like
your the Project Lead does not message
you at 1:00 a.m. even though it's a
fully International time zone
nonexistent kind of or fluid environment
or ecosystem and how do we mement those
at Baseline level so that we can grow
and um we can grow that capacity and
teach people there's a lot of people who
have no idea about how to regulate their
nervous system like that's just a thing
that needs to be implemented in the way
we build things the same way we build
smart contracts building the and and
taking care of those humans building
those smart contracts so I have many
thoughts on this I'm going to hopefully
try to implement some of them hopefully
with people who are into implementing
those things at a protocol level and
then let's see but yeah so so important
quickly uh so since I was like found
that human layer is missing I've been
trying to create a uh experiences that
change energy from the uh head to heart
and body uh since 2018 and I've been
doing a lot of experiments I would love
to share and I think now ethereum space
and especially also developers um I
recently run a very small circle for the
core deps and like really touching their
heart and they really open up and that
they're like this was amazing so I think
experience is what's need it it's not a
word it's not a rule so they have to
experience it unfortunately we only PE
people can have uh access to the
experiences and I was going to suggest
like a and then other friends maybe
Shimona we should work together to
uh bring more people who are really
interested in human design and then the
facilitators who can actually host those
conversations host those spaces and I
think that's another Workforce that we
needed in etheric system to actually
cultivate
that I
think person maybe hello yeah I have to
move the back course I'm very cool there
because of the air okay so there are two
questions uh that I want to ask first is
more personal and second one is more
professional one so along the way of you
know preserving values and culture in
web tree Community what are the things
that you have relearned and un learned
so that's the first question and second
thing the second question is what will
be your main advice to builder in t
country like bmer because I'm from bmer
who want to create a web three culture
and
also uh educate about blog train
initiative and build public goods using
the etherum so that's it two questions
do
you I really like your first question um
and I'm in the beginning of that process
of figuring out what I have to unlearn
and uh what I've had to learn we were
talking about permissionless behaviors
earlier I was acting that way in the
corporate world but not because I
trusted the other humans I was working
with um just because I had a vision and
I was executing and I was being rewarded
for for it um which is not a um
regenerative way of
Behaving now that I am in this space I'm
being challenged to um question that and
to uh find trust first you know a little
bit like the um innocent until proven
guilty U idea uh so first I have to
trust and then we can workshop together
on on something um and that's been a
really on the day-to-day working with my
team working with cross functional
Partners working with vendors uh really
realizing that um this ecosystem was
asking me to look at that um and that's
been very interesting from a personal
development uh
perspective where did you say you were
from from BMA BMA Yar yeah Yar um you
are from the place that um you know
strongly no not from you know like C W
happen in Z but in Central City Central
City like Yangon M so only in the at the
place they are stable so we can build
and build that kind of community and
speace so from that I want to scale it
up to you know yeah yeah yeah thank you
thank you for clarifying um there's like
a strong you know that the long history
of deep shared value culture there but
also that the challenge that country is
facing in also have there is
opportunities for people toearn this
right and then I hope like that's also
was some driving force for you to be
interested in this right um and I
think that type of place like people are
definitely you there are a lot of
curious people should be there um I've
met those people from there too so I
think uh I don't know um I was in Bhutan
the other day and then
because there's a strong like respect or
uh polite people who are there and then
they don't not like a proactive to
they're not really so used to hey let's
have this meet up and open conversation
right like they wait for someone to be
the leader and then hey everyone type of
thing right um but so there's a little
bit of learning that needs to happen
there but if you you can be it's instead
of you like I'm going to create I'm the
leader it's more like I'm going to have
create a space if anyone is interesting
learning together with with me and if
anyone can actually be part of like
teaching others if and so creating a
space actually alone helps a lot and
often if you uh even set a Meetup like
this is how actually a lot of
communities started to happen originary
is oh wow I did not know there's so many
people who are interested in this so
like just you don't need this big event
like you just need can be just at a cafe
or small space you suggest getting
together and it will happen especially
if you are in that that place I'm pretty
sure you can find allies and happy to
connect you with other Burmese friends
who are here oh yeah yeah that great
okay so this is a not I'm going to say
it's a silly question I mean it's a ser
serious question but I'm presenting it
in a very playful manner so you know
take it take with it what you will to
what extent do you think that as the
community grows there's opportunity or a
value to have more of a structured more
of a structure for initiation ritual and
you know I think that my my friends in
Meda my buddy Seth and I talk about this
a lot there you know there are these
examples of these distributed
organizations where the the the concepts
are are sort of centrally developed but
the implementation is distributed the
examples that we think of are the scouts
and also to an extent AA these examples
of these really amazing organizations
that are really implemented by by people
everywhere but there's a central concept
um and to what extent would something
like that be valuable in a in a setting
like this you know going beyond the kind
of Vibes and super permissionless and
like conferences a shelling Point
structure that seems to be in place now
something a bit more structured like
that I think um this just brings up um
for me again like all of these spaces
for initiation it brings up kernel for
me the kernel program that's um it is in
my view it's uh that type of initiation
where it goes like for six weeks uh you
participate in it with others from all
over the world and then you go into
these learnings about again the
philosophy of it the values of it and so
on and then it does dip into if you want
to start building something or you find
somebody within the program and you
start building something then that can
also Happ into mentorship and so on I'm
speaking um having been a mentor in that
like first first um few um kernel blocks
and I think something like that and
developing something like that that you
can take it around and have this
curriculum that you get people to
gravitate towards is this alternative to
the physical space physical event travel
to and so on because again most of it is
online and then it does fold into um
Gatherings IRL when some of these events
happen and so on but that would be a
good model as a suggestion for a
structured thing that you don't
necessarily have to travel to or make
all of that effort I think making
Playbook of holding those rituals in
your Regional Hub I think is really can
be one thing you cannot fly
internationally and I think there is
already things happening and it's not
really obvious because it's a very small
spaces that very curated and for
particular purposes but it's there I
think it's moving really really fast and
then we were going to see way more in
the future but like yeah let's ideate
more about that yeah I think the time
yeah I have a I have a feeling these
people are asking questions probably
they already or someone like Daniel you
probably have an idea too so maybe uh
like we need more people to actually
discuss more and then suggest thing
together with okay part
two part when's part two of this
conversation with everybody who's
here schedule it let's schedule it 15
minutes in 15 minutes yeah um bio break
and then we're back okay um thank you
everybody so much we will try to make
these like a more open thing and maybe
bigger space and maybe more like
prominent on the agenda would you think
I yeah I think so um okay thank you
everybody for coming um and yeah
thank you thank you Sonona thank you Kim
thank you Son thank you everyone thank
you
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
h
m oh
[Music]
is yes
sh e
[Music]
oh
true
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
to
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
all
oh
[Music]
is
the
[Music]
for
is
[Music]
for
sh
[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
h
oh
[Music]
is
come
[Music]
oh
is e
[Music]
for
m
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
e
[Laughter]
[Music]
d
[Laughter]
[Music]
o
n
[Music]
oh
back
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
this
hello hello sorry for the delay we had a
different plan to start but we we will
show a few things which are one is
account recovery uh we have a generic
relayer to send transactions on chain
and one other thing is we have a
registry which we will start with so I
always plan to do it later but
yeah
um so let me show you wait
one okay I'm sorry red just
so anyway hi I'm Dimitri from ZK email
and I would want to show you first the
registry we
built uh can you see that I'll make it
bigger
right
sorry so what you can do with this
registry is basically you can create a
blueprint which will be uh like a
blueprint for what you want to prove
about an email what you want to show and
we will in the background create a ZK
circuit and with this you can then
create proofs about emails with an
SDK
so uh if you go to registry. zk. email
you can check out the site uh and we
show code in a bit but basically what
you will do here
is uh yeah log in first if you want to
create you don't have to log in but if
you want to create the blueprint you'll
have to log in with
GitHub uh let's try this out or actually
I'll show one existing one to make it
this part
easier so obviously you can create uh
any proof about any email but I will
show you a simple example which is just
proving that I'm part of a residen
so basically you would come here you put
some inputs can upload the email to test
which I will do a residency email and
you will fill in some
information
so sender domain the thing is we we have
this chatbot so hopefully it works
because what you actually have to do is
create a
Rex uh which would look like this in the
very end you would add some values and
what you can see is now if I want to
prove something about the header of the
email I would select like the
header U to the max length and write
this reic um
definition so this is the part where our
chatboard will hopefully help it's quite
new so please give us feedback if things
are not working but in this case what I
want to do is I will look for a welcome
text in the
header and say I don't want to reveal
this and the next part is I want to
reveal this so I want to reveal I'm part
of this residency with this
text so you can do all kinds of proofs
let's imagine like for example you want
to um create like a reimburse platform
which someone's building and you want to
create proofs about uh Uber receipt so
what you would do is you would prove uh
you would prove the sender is Uber and
you would find
the the like the amount of the receipt
from Uber and then you can prove
automatically hey this is the amount of
what
um the receipt I got from from Uber and
then you can like do automatic
reimbursement from that for example and
yeah I will skip this cuz right now this
uh like creating this circuit will take
a few hours so if you want to try it out
try one existing one for now um yeah
after you create it it will appear in
the
homepage SE syn
so two things you can do you can first
of course just create proofs on the
website with this so I can upload my
email or use um directed Gmail to
connect and create like a proof
locally um will take a few seconds but
what's more interesting is you can now
also use this in a SDK version
[Music]
so uh let me
see yeah so there is
a sorry can you actually can you see
this so if you go to GitHub SL ZK email/
SDK typescript demo sorry for the naming
so
basically this um I added a demo how you
would use this in typescript
so let's see if this finishes I don't
know if it's the internet but I don't
know if you experienced the kind of slow
internet here as well oh yeah anyway so
now we generated a proof uh you can look
at the proof it will show you generate
some
output and so the email you can only see
in Local Host so we don't save any
emails and if you want you can also we
always deploy a verifier contract on
chain so you can actually verify this
proof how would you use this in a
SDK I guess I have to make this bigger
so if you if if you clone this repo you
will you will get this code so basically
I just added a few examples here um like
for like long running proes and how to
validate inputs before you use them but
in this I'll just give you the short
example so basically what we have here
first what you need is like the
blueprint you created the ID for this
you can basically if you go to our
website uh uh like all of these have
like this um Slug and you can like just
copy
it and put it here so that's one already
added oh sorry for these inlay hands
that's a
bit yeah uh anyway you would you just um
first thing you do you import the
SDK you initialize it so sorry for this
but you can you will in future pass
other options like if you want to
actually create blueprints you have to
pass an Authentication
this is where you actually get the
blueprint you created by the ID so the
one we have in the front
end
uh and from this you can create aover so
we did this uh separately because in
future we want to add client side
proving so let's say if you build
something like a whistleblowing platform
you would you wouldn't want to do this
server side so we're working on a Noir
implementation so it will work front end
anyway and all you have to do is then in
the end pass in an email which I read
here from a file and you will get the
proof output let's actually see if this
works uh so you have to I think I added
the commands in the read me so I
can uh short
example so yeah it will prove it will
wait for the
proof and then it will give you the
proof output and the proof data so yeah
that's basically it what you need to use
a proving system of emails in your front
end this currently only works in the
browser nodejs but still not for nextjs
server side so you can use it in like
nextjs front end but not yet in server
side there's some weird issues we
working on with bundlers but yeah all
right that's for the first demo
um a will tell you a bit more General
things about ZK email and then we will
show you other demos thanks a lot cool
um
okay um okay so I think the way we're
probably going to structure this now
that you guys have a sense of like what
is the registry and how does that work
is trying to get people to sort of
generate their own proofs and so um it's
pretty big crowd but I think maybe what
we'll do is like kind of
um people will try to submit like choose
an email from their inbox and we'll try
to get everybody submit a blueprint to
that Reg registry that you can Define
new kind of prove and then we'll uh send
you guys so the the repo he just showed
of the SDK quick start actually putting
it into an app then we'll put up a QR
code where you can like clone that repo
and then start working on actually
getting an application around that um
maybe just so so I can get like a sense
of like where people are at their level
like maybe raise your hand if you've
like heard of ZK Emil or like are
familiar with ZK email and like know
roughly what like the the proof that
we're actually making is okay something
like half okay maybe we should also
briefly reintro that and then
um other thing is maybe uh raise your
hand if after seeing that you feel kind
of confident that you go to the registry
and make a proof of yourself um and if
not we'll kind of come around and help
okay so raise your hand if you feel
confident with a registry demo um okay a
handful of people Okay cool so maybe
what I'm going to do then is I'm just
going to briefly go over like what is
actually the proof that we're making for
the people who didn't uh managed to make
a do our talk yesterday and then we'll
uh we'll put like a guide up for how to
use a registry and then go around help
people put up the registry proof okay
does that sound good to folks sweet um
okay so maybe just the very basics of
like what what even are we doing here um
so the point is that all of your emails
are signed according to this like deom
protocol so RSA signature of a hash of
all the data in the email and what we
want to do is prove some subset of this
data on chain maybe you want to prove oh
the subject of an email or the fact that
you took an Uber ride for $10 or the
fact that you got into some residency or
something um so the point is uh zkl will
let you prove this whole signature and
then extract the information you want to
extract so maybe you can extract just a
two field or apply some reject to the
body and extract some other selectively
disclosed thing um and the point is all
these tools we put together the registry
SDK Etc make it very easy for you so you
don't have to think about which ZK proof
is happening in the background um the
point is we can keep everything you
don't decide to reveal private uh it's
directly verifying the web to mail
service and not some third party and
you're verifying these on chains will
deploy will help you deploy like
solidity contracts as well if you want
to do that um for some examples I guess
Dimitri already showed you the um the
proof of residency one you can imagine
something like you can build like a very
simple app where you can redact stuff
from email and reveal it um The Hope is
that all of you can build something kind
of similar to ZK PTP with the knowledge
you get here um one example of how ZK
PDP works is they take exactly this
proof that we're going to help you guys
Define of here's an email from my inbox
they do specifically they do it for name
Che transfer emails and they extract the
domain name that was transferred on name
and the fact that it came from name chep
and then they build a Marketplace on top
of that right so now this lets you buy
and sell name domains directly on chain
and so the hope is that we can kind of
get you guys to the point where you've
you've defined this kind of proof um and
you have a say a solidity contract and
now you can start building on top of
that okay cool um yeah so maybe what
I'll do is I'll I'll put up two QR codes
uh for for the registry basically and we
can kind of we can we can get folks
going through this this whole this whole
sequence um and as people have questions
like our team will kind of come around
and also ask the neighbors next to you
like how do you do this thing um but
I'll put up okay so this is a specific
QR code for the registry that you should
go to um might if you're going to do
this on your laptop you should probably
just type in registry. zk. Emil um and
then what I'm going to do is I'm
actually also going to put a QR code to
the uh the docs on the right side so
that if you get lost you can just follow
the docs and then you should be
hopefully good um okay I'll give people
a second to to scan this and go to the
site and and then we'll we'll kind of
try to walk people through now that
you've seen like a demo of what it might
look like we'll try to walk people
through so everyone can do their own
proof
um okay so let me
do
um um
so no we don't have
any we need to leave anyway all right
the
same cool um okay so the first thing we
want I'll put this QR code back up
um okay cool yeah this looks pretty good
okay so the first thing we want folks to
do is find an email from your inbox you
want to make a proof of it can kind of
be uh you know any email but it should
have some data you want to parse out of
the subject or body so I'll give people
like I don't know a few seconds to to go
to their inbox and find some some
interesting email that you want to make
a proof of and then we're kind of going
to go through actually like everyone
should be following through on their own
computer like trying to make this proof
themselves um
cool maybe in this case I'll I'll try to
use this email as an example okay and
then do folks kind of want to walk
around and then make sure people are
like finding emails from their in
um sweet okay I'll give people like 30
seconds to search their inbox find an
interesting email
um okay maybe raise your hand if you
found an interesting email you want to
make a proof
of okay about half maybe raise your hand
if you want another like
minute okay handful of people okay we'll
give people another like 30 seconds or
so
um
yeah I'm
explain cool yeah so once you found this
email um if you're in Gmail you're going
to hit these like three dots and then
you'll see a little thing which is show
original um and you're going to hit that
and if you're an Outlook you'll see one
which is like download original message
uh similar thing you're going to hit
that okay so I'm going to hit
this okay and now you see this like big
document uh of all of all the raw data
this is where we're actually going to
extract information from um
okay cool
um let me try to format this QR code so
it shows up a little better
okay perfect um
sweet okay and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to log in into the registry
I'm going to start making a proof of
that email so I hope people have have
kind of uh found an email I want to make
a proof of open the original message and
open the registry and logged in and gone
to the create blueprint page
um okay so if you you know email's on
the top right the top left of your
screen the QR code is on the top right
this is how you get to the registry um
okay and here I'm going to to name the
pattern let's say you know
alert
uh
Google just say Google Alerts it the one
I'm going to do
um okay
maybe okay maybe raise your hand if
folks have like opened the registry and
have an email they want to make a proof
of okay okay it's like about half um
okay um cool and then you'll notice this
field which is upload test EML once
you've named your pattern you're going
to go to this kind of raw email and
you're going to download original uh in
Gmail's download original an Outlook
you'll have one which is like um
download original message and you'll get
like aeml file and you'll see there's
now this EML file um that just got
downloaded and you're going to upload
this into that little box so I'm going
to click to
upload
okay
um can you did you ever put up that
frend with
uh what that's fine give me give me the
send me
um yeah send send me a link to the um
actually we have the chat GPT we're just
going to use the chat
gbt okay that's fine we can try yeah
what's up
okay um cool okay maybe raise your hand
if you've uploaded the example EML um
sweet okay and then we can start filling
out the fields um you know tags this is
like Google alert um prove you got a
Google alert or some keyword okay um
email query I mean Dimitri explained
this earlier but we're going to fill out
like when I actually search to my inbox
to get this
value you know maybe it'll be like this
um this is going to be the string we
literally put into your email search bar
to fetch that email out automatically so
in this case I'm going to put in you
know Google
Alerts um but you should put in your own
query for what would result when you
search your inbox to get that email
um
cool
um okay and then skip body hash check uh
this is will depend whether you want to
extract information out of the email
subject or body in this case I only want
to extract information out of the email
subject like I want to extract this word
and so I'm going to skip the body hash
check if you want to extract value out
of the body leave the body hash check
okay um Center domain in this case I can
look at the
Domain um you know we'll see this was
sent from google.com and so I'm just
going to take this Google.com I'm stick
it into the center domain cool
okay
um and actually one thing I'm going to
do as well is pull
up let me see if I can
okay and then um this AI I think there's
too many people who are going to trigger
the uh AI Auto extraction right now so
we're likely going to get rate limited
but if you use a chat gbt bot on the top
right then you will not get rate limited
um and then this will let you
automatically extract these fields I can
say something like you know extract
the uh actual value of the being alerted
for from the subject and it should
automatically fill that um but because
we might get very limited you might have
to scan this QR code for the chat gbt
bot and then paste in the email and and
ask you know I want to extract this what
Rex should I use or you can kind of just
manually put in your Rex um although
that might be a little bit harder um
cool and then uh once you're ready uh
you know you can hit save as draft if
you want to come back to this later or
compile blueprint so if you submit the
blueprint then that will basically hit
like our server will start generating ZK
like a ZK circuit for it and actually
generating a unique circuit takes like a
few hours the first time you do it and
so the hope is by the end of you know
this few minute process everybody's at
least submitted a blueprint and if you
come back tonight or tomorrow or
something hopefully it's been generated
and then you can start making proofs of
it but we'll do the rest of the workshop
with like our existing compiled
blueprints um cool do people like have
questions because I know only half the
people yeah okay people want
to have you f up
loading for a
while there might be like a rate liting
happening it right
now yeah maybe I would suggest either
try a different pattern or try reloading
and try again
um so if I go up here this email search
query is literally going to be the thing
in this search bar up here so it's like
if I were to search my inbox to try to
extract that value what would I
literally be searching for and that will
filter my inbox and say these are the
possible emails that might be used as a
valid proof in this proof
so the point is when people actually try
this out they're going to you know go to
to the registry
um and then maybe they're going to use
let me find one of these patterns um you
know I don't know what is a pattern I
can make a proof of um maybe like Google
alerts or something and then I am going
to like uh hit connect like most people
just hit connect Gmail account and then
automatically want to choose which email
to make aof of and the point is once you
connect it'll filter your email Emil by
that email query yep cool good question
um okay uh yeah
question the BL blueprint the submit
blueprint button is what disabled so
that means you've missed some field so
try going through all the fields and
seeing did I feel a field like did I
feel something in the red Jax did I feel
like there's probably some validation
that's failing or you didn't run the
tests
yeah you're getting a yellow
yeah um yeah so so it took you back to
the main page now or wait so so sorry
what exactly did you
click uh which button one one of
these
generate oh yes yeah sorry so so I think
the AI is probably getting rate limited
right now because everybody's quering it
so I'd recommend using the chat GPT bot
in the top right instead
yeah
yeah failed test what what did it
say um yeah probably the Rex format
wasn't exactly correct let me pull up
for you guys what exactly the Rex format
should look like
um yeah let me just pull up an example
kind of Parts there
[Music]
um um right maybe one thing we can do is
provide what exactly those Rexes look
like to help people make the definitions
um okay let me let me pull up an example
pattern that I know should
compile
um probably this
one okay um it's like a bit hard to par
I guess let
me
um let me try to put this in like a
paste
bin
um okay uh we'll probably switch in like
20 30 minutes 20 minutes or so um are
the dots updated the do
okay okay right so this is kind of what
you might imagine I think some folks are
having trouble with the Rex this is kind
of how you need to structure what goes
into to this like Parts Json field is
you need to have like this kind of thing
we have is public and then a Rex
definition is public Rex definition in
this case I'm extracting some value out
of the subject um maybe to make it
concrete for the Google Alerts email um
we can try to do this as well where we
take okay we're going to see Google
alert um so I'm going to say you know in
the subject so before the field you're
extracting you'll have this little like
um thing you have to put of the delimer
before the actual value so here I'm
something from the subject you might
imagine if you're extracting something
from two or from this would say two or
from um and then you're going to put you
know I'm going to see this in the
subject and then I'm going to see any
value except the the SLR and then um the
end of it and so mostly what you'll be
doing is editing this value in the
middle and editing this value whether it
says subject to or from um and your
casing has to be correct like it has to
be subject to from lower case and then
here you put in like what exactly you
want to parse and then probably anything
until the end and then the end delimiter
um okay I think maybe we'll we'll keep
going around and and seeing what
people's questions are uh
yeah uh so so uh you mean like in this
Parts Json
or you could
yeah right yeah so exactly so you'd add
values to extract and you'd put a second
Rex and they'd both be
constrained it's all in the body you
could just put one um it's more about
like Clarity of thought to make sure
that that that kind of uh like you feel
like you're not making it too
complicated in the body um if you're
going to parse in the body by the way
you don't need something that this is
for uh things in the header or subject
if you're going to par something in the
body maybe let's add one to the body um
alert name body um if you're going to
parse in the body you can probably just
directly parse what exactly it is you
want to show so in this case
[Music]
um okay so in this case maybe I want to
parse out I see this in the body um what
I'm going to do is I'm going to uh
Define okay is public equals false
uh okay so I'm going to put up here like
subject Parts Json I'm going to hit here
body parts Jason Okay cool so
um um
so if you're going to do body parsing
you can just say this is the concrete
thing that I'm going to see in the body
and then I'm going to extract out
everything in this case except a quote
after that and this is what's going to
be revealed and so you know hopefully
these subject and body parts Json help
you understand like if I want to parel
that specific value from my subject or
body how exactly I need to do
it yeah
Happ e
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so okay yeah great question if you
want to see like example attributes from
from other patterns uh you can go into
the registry you can say oh I'm kind of
curious how they built um I don't know
this Luma Devcon one you're going to
click this little hyperlink button in
the middle um and this will take you to
the
actual uh
pattern and you're going to hit view all
versions and then you'll see in the
version history you can now edit the old
patterns right if you see that
um so I can go in and I can edit and I
can view what exactly that pattern
looked
like and you can see oh this person to
find an email body and put this stuff
into the parser yeah um so you know
maybe if you look at some especially the
older ones that are compiled these are
ones that we kind of looked at and made
sure they look good and so you know
clicking one of these and then seeing
okay um view all versions and then edit
uh will help you see what exactly should
that pattern look like and you can kind
of use this to help understand okay what
should my like pattern in this Parts
Json actually look like
sweet okay
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a great question so what
is the developer experience of like
actually making sure it's working in
generated output you should see if you
did it correctly like the actual output
that will be generated and so if you see
an error like this oh fail to test
decompose rex on EML then you know you
made some bug on one of these rexes and
so you know I can go through and I can
be like okay like let me try to try to
fix this you know in this case this Rex
you know High Dot is probably not
correct um but in this case you know um
I've gotten like an all test pass ready
to compile and so I know okay like it
looks like this parser actually ran on
my email and so I should be you know
good to good to submit the blueprint um
or at least at the very least save it as
draft and come back to it later if I
don't want to start the compilation
process right now but hopefully the
generative output lets you debug did it
work or not sweet
yeah so so the venmo one used like an
older version of this where they
manually kind of went through but the
venmo one they defined exactly a similar
kind of Rex definition and then they
built precisely uh this kind of thing
but for them the dev tooling was much
much worse like they did not have this
ability to just put in the redx and
everything happens for them in the
background they had to kind of manually
do everything so this will let you build
the r the venmo thing ideally in like
one session like this yep yep um or at
least get all that solidity verification
kind of done for you once the blueprint
just finish submitting and compiling um
sweet
yeah no so so what I'm showing right now
so the the Gmail login stuff is included
for convenience so if I go back to to
here um but if you're using a non-gmail
client uh two things so one is we we
plan to add like non-gmail clients into
this connect Gmail account so we'll add
you know connect out account connect all
this other stuff and if you use
something else you can always drag and
drop and upload the raw EML and so this
will let it work for all non-gmail
accounts yeah um but we'll we'll add IDE
connect Outlook pretty soon sweet Yeah
question in the
back yeah okay yeah um so when you see
the error like failed to test decomposed
rex on email that means this Rex you
defined does not accurately parse your
email
so what I would recommend doing is like
remove one section at a time like maybe
cut you know the last two and be like
okay do I still get the error okay like
put it back do I still get the error and
kind of try to surgically find out okay
if I remove you know maybe these you
know do I still get the error um and try
to kind of figure out where exactly in
your Rex you made the mistake
yep
yeah the pr for yeah so so maybe what
I'll do is I'll I'll demo this chat gbt
bot as well because that will really
help folks um use
it
uh okay
um so so the point is you this will help
create those rexes so maybe what I can
do is I can I can take this uh this raw
EML so let me let me pull up this EML
um okay so I'm going to like copy paste
this EML file I downloaded into the chat
GPT bot and then I'm going to say help
me
extract Thea Rex the part after Google
Alerts
Alert in the
body something like this so I'm going to
paste in the email I'm going to ask like
you know help me generate this Rex to to
do this kind of parsing and then if I
send this out um you it'll take a second
to process
then it'll show us okay what is the name
where should I parse I should parse in
the body um and then it'll give me the
parts array and explain each part so so
you know I'll do
um let me pull this back up um so so
it'll tell me in the first one make is
public false and put you know Google
alert Dash and in the second one make is
public equals true and put you know
anything except this end forward and so
here you know I've changed anything but
the quote because the quote comes
afterwards but this is like somewhat
accurate like I can take
these little is and Rex parts and and
plug it into exactly this kind of a Json
and if I dump that in I should be good
to go and in fact it'll give me this
like Json Parts section that I can just
copy out the parts directly in this like
piece of code it generates um so
hopefully this chat GPT bot helps people
generate the rexes um and can help you
also debug you can say hey I use this as
my parts Json it's not working why where
might the parsing be wrong and the hope
is that this bot has enough prompts of
example patterns from our registry that
it can help you debug
that cool um yeah maybe I'm going to go
around and keep helping people oneon-one
and we'll we'll see um we'll do this for
about seven more minutes and then
transition to the solidity part of the
of the workshop so even if you got
totally super duper lost here um we'll
we'll transition to Something in about
five minutes or so so yeah sweet I I'll
keep going around answering questions
yeah
help the individual
you have to fill all the fields
for e
[Music]
now
for
[Music]
for for
spe e
[Music]
to
don't
[Music]
for for
that's
[Music]
for for
e
oh
[Music]
Okay cool so I'm gonna just briefly uh
explain the main issues that people have
been having and then we're going to
transition to the like other code
sections um okay so some issues that
people were having as I noticed um for
some folks the submit blueprint button
was not enabled um so you have to fill
in all the fields so like you know 64
like the max length is one common one
people missed um you have to put in a
like description you have to put in a
tag and then click enter so it becomes
like a tag type and you have to upload
an email for the the so you have to have
like an uploaded email in this field for
the submit blueprint button to be
available um and at the bottom you have
to see like test pass um if there's no
email uploaded here it won't let you
submit like submit the actual blueprint
at the bottom um I noticed some folks
save as draft um and then triy the
pattern on the on the front page and
realized I couldn't hit create proof so
the main thing there is that you can
only do create proof on the main page if
you've submitted the blueprint and
you've waited a few hours for the thing
to actually compile and for us to make
the circuit for you in the background so
it'll it'll kind of take a a moment for
that to work um yeah so uh and then one
thing is if you if something's going
wrong you can't submit the blueprint you
don't know why I would just save as
draft for now and then we will maybe
send out like a note to folks in the
workshop uh saying hey you know we fixed
some bug where the thing didn't uh
submit the blueprint uh try it again or
something like that um and we'll we'll
put a telegram URL up here for folks to
join and ask questions about hey like is
my blueprint compiled yet kind of what's
going on and we can we can make sure we
help out there um so I'll put up a the
QR code let me see if we have the QR
code somewhere
um
um yeah uh here
okay okay
okay so what I've done is I've stuck the
telegram Link in a QR code over here um
it's the leftmost one if you scan that
QR code you can ask us questions in the
telegram group hey did my patter compile
my my blueprint still not working I
tried to save draft tried to compile
it's not working and we will try to give
support after the workshop and over the
next few weeks and months um my goal is
to get everybody who started a blueprint
here to compile it there are there might
be some bugs on our side like maybe we
we can make the the clarity of why the
parsing is wrong more clear and things
like that and we'll we'll try to make
this better over the next few uh weeks
and months um but at least it sound like
some people were able to fill in all the
fields and get that to work
um yeah uh cool so yeah if you have more
questions I would send to the telegram
but we're going to Pivot uh a little bit
um and maybe one thing I'm I'm curious
about pivoting too is should we I'm
wondering if people will be more excited
to build a front end in which they
import this proof and then now do
something on top of that that or people
will be more excited to do solidity uh
calling zkl proofs on solidity with sent
emails so concretely you know you do
something like
um uh our email based account recovery
um in which you know receiveing email
saying do you want to recover the
account to some some address you receive
an email you reply to it and then that
transaction Triggers on chain um so I'm
just going to do a quick PLL maybe raise
your hand if you prefer JavaScript to
solidity and you want to go over like a
JavaScript version of implementing these
proofs okay like maybe six seven people
okay um raise your hand if you prefer
solidity and you want to go over a
version of triggering transactions in
solidity directly okay that's like 20
people okay so I think what we're going
to do is we're going to sry JavaScript
people um I'll put a link to the
JavaScript demo after we're done with
this and the docs and you can try doing
that yourself um but we'll probably
focus on solidity this time around
um cool um yeah and again if you have
more questions like if you hit up our
Telegram you're like look I really
wanted the JavaScript part of the
workshop uh where's the link for the doc
the SDK whatever we'll we'll send it to
you so the telegram is is really a good
one um okay we're going to we're going
to Pivot a little bit switch gears if
your pattern didn't compile save it as
draft and we'll come back to it later um
so just you know hit hit save as draft
down here um and we can help give
support on the telegram and okay
Switching gears a little bit um so so
maybe briefly before we even like kind
of dive into that I'll give a brief
presentation of what exactly are we even
doing with the solidity style
transactions um so this will be maybe
like a two three minute overview and
then we'll dive into actually building
this ourselves uh so so far what we've
done in the workshop is proving emails
you've received in your inbox um you
know there's all sorts of weird emails
but you would imagine maybe you want to
trigger an onchain smart contract by
sending an email so you have an email a
smart contract controlled by an email
address right so this allows you to do
something something like account
recovery where you can add emails as
Guardians to a Smart wallet and then use
those email addresses to recover that
account um you can have emails on
multisig or directly on a safe if you
add an email and then that email
recovers the account you can have login
with emails where now you can say you
know someone's put an email in an
interface and they've kind of imported
that uh that login and you can have
something like an email wallet where you
receive tokens directly to email and
these are the four examples we've shown
of what happens when an email address
controls a smart contract um but you
know uh you can either use the SDK we've
put out for these four and integrated
into your app and I'll I'll put out the
QR codes for those or you can build your
own custom kind of email triggered
transaction um what does this like
concretely look like uh you'll receive
an email saying you know do you want to
say recover your account or sign on this
multisig or you know log into this
website and all you have to do is reply
confirm and it lets you interact with a
smart contract directly when you reply
we make a ZK proof we receive that email
we make a ZK proof of that signature and
we prove it on chain um this email is
like I've moved the data that's actually
being proved into the subject so we can
all read it but when you actually try
our code this will all be embedded into
the body um but you can see if you read
this like the command you're actually
signing by replying to this email is
recover account eth address from Old
owner eth address to new owner eth
address and this is concretely what
we'll execute on chain um you know so so
the the service we're going to provide
is we're going to deploy a relayer for
you and allow you the option to self
host it when you want the relayer sends
in receives emails and makes proofs so
the user will say like I want to recover
my account the relayer will send them an
email saying are you sure you want to
recover the account if you do reply
confirm to this email the user replies
confirm and then the relayer takes that
reply makes a ZK proof of it sends it on
chain and triggers that smart
contract cool um you know you can accept
Guardian requests um you can anonymize
your email address on chain will
automatically handle making sure the
email is anonymous on chain um and the
point is a relayer decentralized so you
can start with our hosted relayer just
so you can get a prototype up and then
run your own server when you feel ready
to um sweet um so maybe what I'll do is
I will put up uh I'll briefly go through
what the interface actually looks like
and then we can um we can look at the
various sdks and things like that um so
uh okay
so I guess maybe the first thing I'll go
over is if you actually want to add
let's see want to add a specific version
of one of those four ideas like say
account recovery to your application you
probably wouldn't use a generic
transaction Builder you'd automatically
use the recovery version that we
deployed so in this case you know we've
deployed a recovery module that you can
just add to any smart account so how
would you do that um you would take our
solidity you know smart contract you'd
install it on your wallet and then you'd
hit our API with these different
acceptance request recovery request
complete request again keeping in mind
you can always self-host this API if you
want but you can start with ours just
for East of convenience um when you
actually want to add the smart account
into you know a wallet on a front end
you can use some code like this that
we've already kind of configured for
people deploying this account recovery
to a wallet um the docs will be like
your your friend here so if you look oh
I want to do account recovery and search
it in the docs you'll be able to pull up
that page and like okay this is exactly
what I need to do to integrate it um but
maybe the thing we'll focus on this
Workshop is getting generic solidity
commands to work
um so you know in this case you would
maybe want to build your own version of
this kind of email trigger transaction
let's say you wanted to build account
recovery you would Define something like
recover account eth address to new owner
eth address you define a solidity
function looks exactly like this a
recovery subject template that you know
takes in string memory returns templates
that just defines the pattern and you
plug in you know in this case I've done
you know um curly braces eth address or
I want eth addresses you can also put
strings numbers whatever and so let you
you automatically access those values
from within solidity um and you would
hit our API with a query like this our
quick start will automatically do this
end to-end thing for you and you can
kind of just fiddle with it oh what if I
change the word account uh from account
to wallet what if I change an eth
address from an eth address to a string
and this will let you experiment with
this as a starting point um okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to um
maybe what I'll even do is I'll link to
a more specific point in the docs um
where we have this kind of
uh this sort of generic relayer thing
going on let me pull up uh where exactly
we have this um quick start okay so I'm
going to link everyone to this quick
start um this is concretely
in email
um cool so you can either go to docs
email email transaction off this is our
email transaction Builder and then the
quick start or you can just scan this QR
code
um if you're on your laptop you play one
to the bottom one if you're on your it's
not really possible to run solity on
your mobile so I wouldn't recommend
scanning from your your phone and then
we'll we'll basically show once you've
got uh okay so I'll I'll leave this QR
code up for a little bit once you've got
this uh this QR code scanned um
then uh I guess the detail will take
over what exactly should you do with
this quick start running through
actually cloning the repo going through
these docs Etc so I'll give people like
30 seconds to make sure you've scann
this QR code make sure you have this
link on your computer you're at docs
email email Tx off quick start and we'll
we'll go from there
um I'll make this uh bigger okay I'm G
give you 10 seconds to take this and
then we're gonna we're going to move to
what exactly do with the quick
start okay everybody has scanned I hope
so you have like three seconds um okay
cool now we're going to swap to once
you're on this quick start page um you
know we're going to actually go through
this git cloning CD in um setting your
environment and then actually deploying
cool you want to take over sure
cool um so hey everyone um I'm a here
and the entire point for this particular
section of the workshop is to show that
how easy we have sort of made to do an
onchain
transaction like specifically to a
contract function purely by by replying
to an email so if you want to integrate
um people just replying to emails and
that triggering an onchain transaction
this is like a really brief demo for
that um cool so maybe just quickly one
question can people read the screen like
from the back it looks a little bit
maybe raise your hand if you can read
the Tex that's good okay good okay
should be fine cool um yeah so if anyone
hasn't been to the docs page yet it's
docs. proof. email you come to the email
transaction OD section and in there you
just click to Quick
Start I'll give people half a minute to
a minute to do this
um yeah just do the first step you just
need to clone um a get repel and CD into
the
directory can I have a show of hands of
um of people that have done
this cool I can see five six hands seven
eight nine cool um yeah so I'll continue
I'll just
so once you have sort of um cded into
the directory um I would recommend you
to run this one command this is um one
package that you might need I'll just
screen yeah so it's Brew install JQ just
do this if you don't have a few of Macs
probably have this couple of don't so
this is just like a sanity of
installation um
cool and once you have done the
installation um just go back to the docs
page um scroll down and you would see
this one make Command um I would ask you
to copy this command paste it into your
terminal and
then just enter your email address so
this is my email address um and you can
enter your email addresses as well once
you submit this you should receive a
response with a status
success got it
cool got
it um the command is in the docs so if
you just scroll a bit down it is make
space Sumit space Capital email equals
your email
address and for people who have done
this already what you would have
received is that if you go to your email
you would have received a very templated
email um it would look something like
this once this step is complete and um
yeah I would recommend you to just reply
to it it doesn't matter what you're
typing in as long as you're replying to
the email um it is good
enough people need help and are not
show off hands people who have done
it cool five
people anyone from there having any
issues
5022 um just run again this is okay so
why you would have been receiving 502 is
that we are also making an Alchemy check
for checking that is any transfer of
data or approval of erc20 tokens are
sort of being done um and to avoid that
there's an Alchemy simulation check and
that would have rate limited so just try
again and um I will be giving the
overview of this as well
[Music]
cool so for people sort of basically
asking that what did we actually do okay
we replied to an email and um if I was
to show you the email um just give it
some
time yeah some few of the folks would
have received an email like this where
it would have said your UD has been
complete view on Explorer you can see
this one transaction that has happened
so what did you really do by replying to
an email um if you sort of go over the
actual
contract in the repository that you just
cloned you would find yourself um a
contract that is already been deployed
you could have deployed this yourself
and then made few changes but what
essentially is being done in this
particular contract is that we have
created an email off contract for you
and what it does essentially is that it
allows you to create commands um and
what do I mean by commands commands look
something like this you can have
multiple commands and the meaning of a
command is that you can trigger things
with it so every specific command does
something if you could have like an
approv erc20 command you could have that
oh swap my erc20 token if this
particular command is run or send money
to this particular e address if that
particular command is Rong
um for the sake of this particular
demonstration um all of these commands
emit um an event and um there are
different sort of uh templates or
placeholders that you can use you can
use a string you can use U eth address
etc etc and you can have the complexity
of the command as you want so if I if
you were to go into docs um I have
this example of commands that you could
have used
um where is
it cool so the example of commands can
be for example send decimals tokens to e
address and this is a templated command
and while filling the parameters you
could have specified 2.5 tokens to this
particular address and you create these
commands and essentially you would be
creating this contract um where you have
the command templates and the actual
function that we are hitting with the
make Command is the emit email command
function and what it essentially is
doing is that you have something called
as template ID you're Computing the
template ID and if the email proof is
being verified then at the end you're
emitting an event so you can have your
own custom logic at the end of the email
proving um step and once the email has
been proven and a particular command has
been run then you can have your whatever
logic you want at the end of the
function and what is it is it'll
essentially do is that it'll verify your
email proof and then at the end run that
command and if I was to show you the API
call that is getting made at the
[Music]
end the call looks like this I hope this
is
visible okay cool um the contract
address is the contract address that you
would have deployed in this particular
case the contract address is for this
particular contract that's the emit
email command contract you have a deim
contract address um this DM address
contract um can be found in the either
email
orer
so if you go to this particular repo you
will find the dkim contract so you
mention that you can also use the
existing dkim contract which you can
find in the make file
account code function ABI so this is
basically the ABIA of the function that
you want to hit in our uh case it is the
emit email command so the ABIA that is
getting used is for this particular
command thank
you you can specify which email address
it is getting sent to you can specify
the subject you want you can specify the
body and the chain you want to do it
also your function can have more more
parameters other than the struct that we
are constructing so for example in this
particular function you have the owner
address and a template index that is an
address in a un type so you can add the
remaining arguments at the end of it and
what this essentially does is that you
trigger a relayer which would send a
email to the user once the user has
replied to the email our IMAP server
will pick up the email it will send it
to our approver which will create a ZK
proof of that particular email and then
um it will hit on chain the transaction
that you want to hit so the command SL
function in the contract that you want
to hit so all of this is actually
abstracted for you and we are handling
all these process so for you you only
would be needing to deploy a contract
and hit our API with the specifications
that me uh that was
mentioned cool um
all this is taking
time was this clear anyone having
issues yes
so
I think this stage
think
e
for
[Music]
for for
h
[Music]
uh okay can you just tell them the
minutes late and help can you can you
[Music]
help okay that's fine okay yeah
see e
yes
Okay cool so as we're coming to the last
seven minutes here maybe I'll just
address some of the last few uh last few
notes um some folks mentioned wanting to
self-host if you go to this repo on
GitHub um you can basically clone it
locally and you'll see all the packages
and infrastructure that this relies on
and you can self host the relayer if you
want um and the API interface should be
exactly the same
um if you want to integrate any one of
the specific things like account
recovery on the left email signers oath
login or email wall that's already been
built and audited for you um you can use
one of these four QR codes um and if you
want um these are the main QR codes
questions on the left side on the
telegram our website in the middle at
zk. email and these slides on the right
side so you can kind of go through
yourself and be like oh what were all
those other QR codes that I missed um so
these are kind of the most important
things to scan um and we'll kind of be
around to keep taking question but I'm
I'm hoping that people came away from
this um with a sense of like one how can
I define proofs of emails in my inbox
even if potentially you know we we
didn't exactly get all of them compiling
um hopefully that at least gave folks
some insight and then also how can I get
proofs of emails triggering onchain
transactions I hope people got at least
an idea of here's an MVP way to do it
when I want to put into production I can
use one of the audited versions up here
or I can kind of uh you know read the
docs and and build one myself um again
please ask questions in our Telegram and
we will be around the ZK email impact
booth for the next two days um it's kind
of on the opposite corner of the
building on this floor um there's a
bunch of impact booths and you can see
us you can come to us you can be like
hey I really wanted to get the proof
from my workshop compiling can you help
me and some of them will be at the booth
and we will get the thing compiling um
and so yeah definitely meet us at the
impact Booth if you want more
information um and if you like account
abstraction you want to debate it with
us we'll be at the account abstraction
Community hub
um yeah definitely come see us at any of
these um but I'll leave these up for for
another like few minutes and hopefully
folks can uh can grab these
and yeah keep keep asking us questions
me said the impact with if you didn't
get it compiled um sweet thank you for
coming um and I hope that people were
able to learn at least something from
this and we also have a talk that we
gave yesterday that will be live stream
that you um that was live stream that
you can go and and listen on like okay
how exactly does all this stuff even
work like what is happening the
background and you can get a lot more
insight from that on our docs okay thank
you
[Applause]
guys for
be giving a workship after you yeah I
hope yours is uh super lit I'm excited
[Music]
oh
for
[Music]
[Applause]
s
[Music]
present maybe this here but what I don't
know is how do I present
[Music]
oh
sorry unplugg you
what happened there
s
oh it's already there
perfect thank you hi everyone for all of
those of you joining for the designing a
reround uh Workshop please we're going
to ask you to
seat according to who which group you
belong to so the exercise that we're
going to be doing in this Workshop is
I'm not sure how many of you are
familiar with retro rounds retroactive
funding
rounds yes I see some hands going up um
if you're part of an ecosystem like you
are a protocol or you want to design
around to
incentivize uh growth or different
things in an ecosystem we're going to
ask you to please sit on the left side
of this area uh everyone please try to
to come over to the middle if you are
looking to design around for a community
say you're a local community and what
you're trying to incentivize is growth
or different goals within your local uh
geographically local community or
community of a different type uh we're
going to ask you to sit on the right
side and this is because we're going to
be
making uh you're right so here
yeah perfect so communities over here
ecosystems on this side uh and this is
because we're going to have breakout
groups so this is going to be a very
Hands-On Workshop you'll be working or
collaborating with two or three other
people that are here to go through the
process of designing a reer
around and it's best if you are sitting
or partnered with those that are on the
same wavelength of who your audiences
are going to be what are the type of
values or behaviors that you want to
incentivize so that is why please
ecosystems to the left and communities
to the right
it's your
right yeah ecosystems is on the on the
left which is your left so if you're I'm
sorry I think oh that's somewh so
ecosystems to the left and communities
to the right
perfect we're going to be handing out
some posted notes so that it's easier
for you to uh brainstorm uh usual uh
advice from workshops one idea per
posted note is going to make it a lot
easier for you all to know what to do
with these different
ideas
and
okay commun is here
to the
right
and I think this will also come clear
and happy to go over any questions
around seaing when we get to the
breakout
groups
perfect so before diving right into it
how many of you know what retroactive
funding rounds are can
I Boop poop there we go yes yes um can I
get a hands up from those of you that
know what a reround is if not because
I'm just going to walk through
it perfect so one of the reasons why
we've been experimenting with rer rounds
as of late is the fact that it is is
meant to be easier than running a
proactive grants programs right in a
proactive grants programs program what
you're trying to do basically is predict
the future you're trying to understand
if people are going to do what they say
and promise that they are going to do
you're trying to predict if this is
still going to be relevant to your
ecosystem or to your community by the
time it is done and you're trying to
assess as well
if the team that is doing it is going to
be capable of doing it so basically
we're trying to fulfill the role of a VC
when we're not VCS when we don't have
that information when we don't have the
tools that VCS
have and this is why or through this
logic this other mechanism came up and
vitalic uh came up with it or right
about it not came up with it but right
about it and the
most relevant thing here is that in
reach rounds we expect that it's easier
to agree on what was
useful rather than trying to predict
what is going to be
useful and so retroactive rounds are a
funding
mechanism um you might have heard them
as retroactive rounds which is the
latest rebranding that optimism has
given to this funding mechanism but
previously and I think it's more widely
known as reter pgf retroactive public
goods funding
rounds and in this is a funding
mechanism that has two sides of it the
first one is we have a results Oracle
this results Oracle can be a group of
people it can be a smart contract but
right now all of the forms in which
we've seen it have been groups of groups
of people that reward projects that they
recognize as having had and as having
already provided value either to an
ecosystem or to a
community however we know that the
design of this Oracle is actually a
complicated thing so what we've seen as
well and what is expected of this
retroactive rounds is that we have them
running over and over again because
we're experimenting with the design of
these rounds which is also what we're
going to be exploring today in this
Workshop we're not expecting to have the
best design from the get-go we know that
we're going to learn and get closer to
this best design in an iterative way
we're going to be trying out different
hypothesis we're going to be trying out
different variables we will be engaging
different audiences and through that
process we expect to get to a better
outcome of how these allocations are
done and uh I will mention that
retroactive funding is not a new thing
this is not something that was invented
in the web 3 space we actually have
institutions that have been running this
type of funding rounds for really long
times and maybe I'm not sure who knows
what this is but this is the noble price
or like the Insignia that is given as a
Nobel Prize and the Nobel priz is one of
the best examples of a reg interactive
funding program people that are granted
Nobel prices have been are people that
have done research usually like decades
ago and it's until it has been proven
that this research has been really
meaningful to society that they get
awarded a cash prize and a lot of other
things that come with being a noble
laurate um but this is the it's a
similar experiment that we're running
with retroactive rounds in which we're
looking at what has done what has
yielded a very valuable contribution to
an ecosystem or to a community and we
want to reward that because we want to
incentivize more people to have this
type of behaviors of contributing to the
communities or to the
ecosystems so one of the things that I
suggest for all of those thinking of
running retroactive rounds is this is an
iterative process and it takes time it
is
um resource intensive so don't try to
run it's not going to be perfect at the
first time it's going to require several
iterations and you will need to take
your time and going through this
process
okay so this is a mechanism that was
made Popular by optimism optimism has
around already six rounds we are
currently or we just closed I think one
one day ago the latest sixth round um
optimism for those of you that don't
know it is an L2 that has committed to
this funding model from inception from
the moment in which optimism minted its
token they decided that the fees
generate and its model they decided that
the fees generated by the sequencer were
going to be directed to this mechanism
and is they are going to be used to fund
public goods and to fund projects that
are creating uh that are providing an
impact or benefits to the
ecosystem they've been also pioneering
in the experimentation of this mechanism
so while they started with a small round
in 20 back in 2021 in which they gave
out about 1 million USD and had a small
subset of Voters this has continued to
grow and evolve throughout the years
their largest round was in 2023 in which
they dis they allocated over 30 they
allocated about 30 million op through
different categories and they had a set
of about 140 voters they've also been
experimenting with other type of rounds
like the latest fourth round in which
they used a me um voting style called uh
metrics like impact metrics people voted
and impact metrics instead of projects
but it's been going back and forth in
between voting for projects or for
metrics
and this is something that they've
committed 850 million op throughout the
rest of the life and this is only what
was allocated at the Inception of the
token there's also all of the funds that
are being generated through sequencer
fees that are going to continue with
this uh that are meant to continue this
mechanism or funding this
mechanism it's important to note though
that optimism is not the only ecosystem
running reter round
there's already been several rounds run
by other ecosystems such as filecoin
that is currently running its second rer
round there's also pocket which ran its
uh its own round at the meet this year
interestingly also using the funds that
they received from the optimism Reacher
around and funding that they received
from arbitrium to reward its own
contributors there's also the cell
ecosystem that ran around earlier this
year and is looking to run another round
at the end of this year and the leaf P2P
library or Leaf P2P ecosystem that has
also run its own reer around to fund uh
those that have been providing value to
this um to this
library in and in addition to that it's
not only ecosystems that can use this
mechanism but we've also seen local
communities using this mechanism to
incentive device specific types of
behaviors so one of the really nice
things about Reacher rounds is that what
you're doing is you're creating a
feedback loop of behaviors that you're
incentivizing that are going to enable
your community or your ecosystem to get
to a goal right so while we can see that
for ecosystems this may be growing your
tvl making your users more sticky or
growing the number of your users we can
also see that local communities that are
trying to onboard more people into web 3
that are trying to become more
regenerative can also use this mechanism
to incentivize this type of positive
behaviors and people will know that this
is something that is going to continue
to happen and this type of behavior will
continue to be rewarded as long as these
rer rounds are run with um like there is
this expectation that this rounds will
continue to run so we've also seen
groups such as as Dow drops which ran
one retroactive round as such earlier
last year whom they were uh targeting
was ethereum contributors regardless of
which al2 or which ecosystem within the
ethereum ecosystem they were um they
were contributing to and what their type
of contributions were we've also seen
local communities such as eth Colombia
and ethereum Mexico host their own
rounds and we've also seen other educ
Community such as cryptoversity that
also doing this type of experiments to
incentivize more people in particular
behaviors that they find relevant to
their
communities and so as I mentioned before
Reacher rounds are mechanisms and
there's four five steps that I usually
look at when designing
mechanisms um and when I that I usually
look at when designing mechanisms and
that it's good to keep in mind because
these affect like the steps and as we
scope them affect the rest of the
process and it's also important to think
of it as multiple steps because this
means that you can change the things and
the sub mechanisms that are part of the
mechanism design or in this case the
Retro mechanism so first we have funding
and when we're thinking of the Reacher
rounds sometimes you don't need to worry
about funding sometimes you're optimism
and you just have funding but if you're
a local round or you're a local
community that wants to host a round you
need to think about where am I going to
get the funding for running this round
not only to run the operations of this
round but also what where am I going to
get the funds to give out to the
community because they've done the
behaviors that I want to incentivize
second is the design of the round and
when I talk about design I'm not talking
about the images that we're going to use
or the fonts or the colors that we're
going to use but who the audience is
what is it that I'm trying to
incentivize all of this work that leads
up to the round and we also have the
data aggregation So based on the design
that you're using based on the things
that you're trying to incentivize and
based on your audience you're going to
be able to determine what are the type
of metrics and data that I can use to
measure if people have actually people
or projects have actually generated
value to my ecosystem or to my
community this is the why the how and
the what then third we have the decision
making so what we've seen so far has
been groups of people in different sizes
voting on who gets the funding but
there's other ways in which we can have
this decision-making process take place
this could be two different groups of
voting uh groups that vote you can have
one group that votes then people review
the vote they approve it or decline it
and this is why I wanted to call out
there's this decision-making process
which can be its own mechanism then
there's the dispersement process or
dispersement mechanism which can be
you're streaming the tokens over a
certain amount of time or you're giving
the lumsum and then you have really
important postmortem analysis you
definitely want to look at how you're
run went to understand if you did the
right things when you were designing
your round and the then in this Workshop
we're going to focus on the design
because this is the most relevant part
of your round if you don't get the
design for your round right you won't
know if you are actually achieving the
goal that you wanted to achieve and
therefore you won't know if you're using
your resources in the most efficient and
effective way to achieve your goal which
means you're not going to be able to
evaluate if the program that you just
ran actually made a difference for your
ecosystem or for your community and if
you should even think of running it
again so why are we going to focus on
the design and the scope first is we
have a lot of participants and a lot of
audiences that participating around each
of them have different incentives but
this is a game that we're all playing
together and we want to make sure that
we're aligning everyone's incentives so
that we're able to get to the goal so we
want to be
specific uh also around what the
incentives are that we want to have in
view in the community or in the
ecosystem and it's essential as I
mentioned for knowing what the what the
goal is is going to be essential for us
to know if it worked second it's also
going to help us improve the stakeholder
management this can be a very time
intensive process so we want to make
sure that people know what they are
supposed to do when they are supposed to
do the things and why they are supposed
to do these things if we're asking them
to vote if we're asking them to review
projects if we're asking them to provide
specific data we need them to understand
why they are doing these things so that
the retround it the retround itself can
be successful number three is we want to
mitigate risks through the design we
want to understand and recognize what
are the unknowns in this design what are
the variables that we're unable to
influence or that we're unable to
control in these experiments and we also
want to know what could go wrong and if
there is something that we can avoid
that we can do to avoid it going wrong
and the fourth one is we need to
optimize our resources specifically for
local community rounds I know that
ecosystems tend to have a lot of funds
and this is also what enables them to
experiment with this type of uh of
mechanisms but this may be something
that local communities cannot afford
because it's they are either being
funded one by one or they have a more
limited Runway which means that you need
to be able to pick your battles in terms
of where you're allocating your funding
you need to be able to clearly identify
where should you be putting your time
where should you be putting your funds
and where should you be directing the
attention of your community when you're
running these type of rounds you want to
identify what are the most high impact
areas that you want to be uh focusing
your initial or your first iterations of
the rounds
on and in terms of incentives as I
mentioned before with this type of
mechanism we're looking at not
predicting we're not trying to predict
the future we're trying to assess what
has already been useful so we want to
align incentives so the hypothesis here
with this mechanism is that people out
there will build what matters to this
ecosystem or to this
community and once they've generated
this value they're going to be rewarded
for it but if we're not telling them
properly what is it that this ecosystem
needs or if that is not clear and um
it's not of common understanding for the
community it's going to be very hard to
have people building the things that are
actually doing meaningful work for the
ecosystem and for example this is
something that we've seen in optimism
and that we've seen in some of the other
rer rounds in which there's a lot of
work that is being done
but this is not exactly what is needed
or we see multiple versions of the same
thing being replicated and not being
used by the Target audiences that people
are trying to save time or improve their
work if we're not and this stems from a
lack of communication and a lack of
clarity in terms of where is the
ecosystem headed what is actually needed
what is still going to be useful in 3 4
5 6 months from now so if we give this
information either as local community or
ecosystems to the audience like to the
community members we're going to be able
to get them excited of contributing to
the ecosystem and know that they will be
receiving a reward and we will avoid
having
to like have them lose Faith or hope in
this mechanism or process by building
something that is not going to be
rewarded because it wasn't impactful or
useful and as I was mentioning this
predictability of having these rounds is
going to create reliability you want to
have your Builders or the members of
your community know that the round
there's going to be multiple rounds so
they are going to continue behaving in
this particular way that you've said you
want through this mechanism what we're
doing is we're creating new behaviors
we're asking people to actively change
what they do with the expectation of a
future reward and this change in
behaviors happens over time it's not
going to happen from one day to another
and it's not going to be cemented only
after one round so it's also important
that as we continue to iterate on these
designs and on these rounds we make sure
that we're not completely disrupting the
expectations from the participants
because it's going to make it really
hard to keep the Behavior Keep
incentivizing
behaviors that we want to see in the
ecosystem
see so I'm going to stop very quickly
there because now we're going to jump
into the breakout
groups um do you does anyone have any
questions so far on to rer
rounds no perfect so next thing that
we're going to do is we're going to
design our own rer round yes I
have can I project okay all
right
testing uh I'm just curious if you could
share some more examples of retro rounds
and what are the
differences in the round as you change
what you're funding like if it's
software or if it's governance or if
it's something else
thanks yes so
the depending on what it is on who your
audience is and what their capabilities
are for example in terms of oo perfect
uh in terms of generating different data
that you want to aggregate for people to
vote um depending on how much funding
you have depending on precisely the
things that you're looking to fund and
incentivize uh you're going to have
different one different types of
communication that you're having with
them uh there's also going to be as I
mentioned different types of data that
you're going to be gathering so for
example I um designed and ran The Ether
Mexico round what we were focusing on
there was this is a geographically
specific round and what we were looking
to incentivize where
five different things in the community
we wanted people that were prioritizing
onboarding others into the web 3
ecosystem so we were looking at an
increase on on wallets regardless of
which chain this was happening in so I
think this is also going to be one of
the main differences that you might see
from local communities versus ecosystem
specific communities uh sorry ecosystem
specific rounds in which ecosystem
specific rounds will look to increase
the value to their own ecosystems which
makes sense in that it is their funding
and they have goals that they need to
achieve within their own ecosystem to be
successful um so you'd be looking at
more specific metrics such as I
mentioned tvl number of users number of
transactions am um transaction size or
if it's librar is number of uh projects
that are using this Library within my
ecosystem um then on the community
rounds uh what we've we were
experimenting with in The Ether Mexico
Community was looking at number of
people onboarded into web 3 we were also
looking at reducing the gender gap so
number of like projects that were
specifically targeting onboarding women
or supporting women in the web 3 space
we were we're also looking at refi
communities in Mexico so looking at how
many had interacted with local
regenerative projects how many of them
had onboarded local regenerative
projects or use cases in the refi space
uh we were also looking at education so
Partnerships with universities and these
were some of the type of behaviors that
we were trying to incentivize in the
long term as well so for us
uh let's say that an ecosystem would be
uh pushing for a growth on number of
users in their own ecosystem we were
pushing for a number of new users or new
attendees to web three events CU our
hypothesis and this is also where the
designing and understanding well what is
your North Star and what is your goal is
really relevant because it's what we are
trying to incentivize in the long term
is we want to have more people educ ated
and participating in the web 3 space
that would be one in terms of like
onboarding second we want to see more
women integrated into the space so
allocating funding to that as well uh I
would say those are two of the main
difference that we've observed I know as
well that I believe ethereum Colombia
one of the things that they were
incentivizing as well is number of
people running their own noes um so how
people are actively participating in
securing ethereum uh but those are some
of the the things that are Stark
differences and I think also another
thing that is very dependent on whether
it's an ecosystem or a local community
thing is um local communities are very
different from one another in terms of
the things that are needed in one
country or one city are going to be very
different from what's needed in a
different country or a different city
and how we framed as well the round that
e Mexico ran is we want to fund the
edges where impact is happening and this
impact might not be clearly understood
by someone that is very far away so say
even if this is impact that they are
onboarding everyone into optimism this
might be very difficult for optimism to
recognize from such a far away point of
like oh why is this relevant in Mexico
in this type of scenario but this is
something that local communities if they
are the ones running the round if they
are the ones designing and determining
what is impactful in this specific
situation or in this specific uh
reality they're going to be better able
to identify and understand why this was
impactful and why it should be rewarded
so I also think that one of the big
difference is how close you are to the
impact that is being
generated so that people are able to to
identify it and fund it
that's a very broad
spectrum hello so I have a question I
had a question about how you can measure
the postmortem analysis and I was
thinking
like that should be
done I was thinking about how an
ecosystem that
runs pgf rounds retro pgf rounds can
make the postmortem analysis and I was
thinking like this is a whole design
space on how you can do that how you can
measure
the how much you incentivize the project
that from the previous round compared to
the next round after one year so yeah my
question is
how how for example the analysis of
previous Optimist rounds happened
[Music]
perfect so for each of the optimism
rounds there has been hypotheses that
are set at the beginning of the rounds
in terms of lessons learned from the
previous rounds and then why are they
making the design changes that they are
doing with it's sort of like we are say
now we're going for impact metrics based
voting and we're doing this because we
expect that people are going to have an
easier time deciding which type of
metric is more relevant to them they
won't have to we're going to be reducing
time because they not be reviewing each
of the projects and then once the voting
comes to an end and allocations are done
there's usually also an exit survey that
is sent and all of this data is then
aggregated to understand do we I think
this one has been more of a sentiment
analysis on like do we feel confident
that the allocation was done better in
comparison to round three um there's
still room a lot of room for improvement
to be quite honest in terms of analyzing
the postmortem of the rounds
specifically when it comes to the impact
that funding has had on the projects uh
I think for some of the rer rounds this
is still um is still to be done um and
there are some I think open subserver
has done some in terms of one year after
Rich pgf 3 to project have projects
continue to build on optimism and
continue to ship and generate value in
the ecosystem I think that's one good
approach uh something else that I know
um like SEL myself and others have been
exploring is can we create
counterfactuals to understand if this
injection of capital or injection of
funding to the projects actually made a
difference if we were to look at this in
the future had they never received
funding would it still look the same uh
which can help us understand if this
actually makes a difference for this
type of projects or in this type of
situation but I think that is still
pretty nent uh and not a lot of it yeah
I know that not a lot of it or none of
it has been done
yet okay perfect
so um
okay so we're going to get into breakout
groups of three to four people um they
can let's see I think five can also be
good um but if you can just get together
um so perfect I think we have three here
uh see Jal is going to help us as well
in terms of like putting together with
the
groups um do you want to get
together one hello
perfect
okay yeah just come over
here do you have things to ride with
okay
perfect and what we're going to be doing
is we're going to go through a set of
prompts
and the first one
is we're going to go through a set of
prompts and this is going to be the
process through which we design a
retroactive round you can choose
whichever whether you want to design it
for a community you can choose whether
you want to design it for an ecosystem
for example I see the gitcoin team here
maybe they want to design a return
around for members in their
ecosystem um I see different people from
Lam communities over there maybe they
want to design it for a Latin American
Community something that Cal and I were
also brainstorming uh earlier on this
Workshop is someone and it might be an
experiment that SEL and I do right now
as well is what if we were to design a
rer round for
Devon so anyone can take that prompt up
as
well and so the first prompt is is we're
going to ask you to introduce yourselves
in your group in case you don't know
each
other please make it short because we
are going to have eight minutes for this
first prompt so introduce yourselves and
choose your
adventure uh choose who are you
designing this retro round for is it for
a local community is it for an ecosystem
and just agree with the other members of
your team which audience you're looking
to engage with is it going to be again a
local community is it going to be an
ecosystem and if you have any questions
throughout this process please raise
your hand and say J or myself we'll walk
to you
and um yeah answer any questions that
there may be we're going to have eight
minutes for this so please introduce
yourself share why you're in this why
you're in this workshop and if you're
part of a community or an ecosystem and
then decide who are you designing this
round for
go yes if you have any questions just
raise your hands and say y or myself
will come
FOC
[Music]
so
h
[Music]
to
your
you
[Music]
all
m
[Music]
oh oh
sh
[Music]
oh
we have 1 minute left so please come to
a decision
of what Adventure you're going to follow
for the next prompt
m
[Music]
and time is up so please I hope you've
written down H either in one of the
posted
notes as well like just or somewhere
else what is the adventure that you're
going to follow if you're going to be uh
designing this retro around for a local
community or if you're thinking of it as
a web3 ecosystem or ethereum as a whole
or
Devcon so the next prompt that we're
going to be looking at is based on your
groups and based on who you've decided
to design this round for you will be
defining what is the North Star that you
want to
achieve and here is what the North Star
is what is the end goal that we want to
reach what is the end goal that you want
to reach within this community what is
the end goal that you want to reach
within this
ecosystem and it's important as I
mentioned before to know this because if
we don't know where we're going then
we're not going to be able to tell if
we've gotten there or how we're going to
get there and this means we're not going
to be able to measure what are the type
of what's the type of data and what are
the type of metrics that would be useful
for us to leverage when we're deciding
who should be funded and we're also not
going to know what are the type of
behaviors that we want to incentivize
for people to follow that are going to
get us closer to this hypothetical
goal and I will incite you as well to
think of this not as a short-term goal
it could be a short-term goal but it's
better to think of it as long-term goal
like if you're doing this for a local
community how do you want this community
to look 50 years from now 60 years from
now what is this like bright future that
we're aiming
for and as I mentioned before you can
have it be a one-year goal I know that a
lot of the ecosystems plan in more short
term because it makes sense for what
they trying to do uh but try to aim for
this long-term Vision even if you're an
ecosystem we want to play Infinite games
which means we're incentive iing
behaviors that are going to be healthy
for what we're trying to achieve in the
long
run and so the second prompt is Define
with your team members what is the North
Star that you're going to be fulfilling
for this either local community or
ecosystem what is the overarch and here
are some questions that will help you in
defining this North Star and here feel
free to use the posted notes and
remember one idea per posted note that's
going to make it a lot easier when
you're looking at the different ideas
that you have what is the overarching
objective that you hope to achieve by
running this round as well not only this
round but like in the long term and how
does this round how can this line around
with this overarching goal then what is
the long-term Vision that you have for
your community or for your ecosystem and
what are going to be your goals for this
round and so for this one we're going to
have about 10 to 12 minutes I think it
might be too much but we'll be going
around and if it is too much we'll just
qu it
short so go
[Music]
on for
h
[Music]
I
that is interes
[Music]
yeah and we just had a really good
question on whether it's like oh should
we just have one Northstar um what I
would suggest is you each of you write
uh what are some of the things that
would be very relevant to have in this
round write it in a posted notes and
then you share them like you paste them
in the middle for everyone else to see
and then people can either agree or
disagree with the things that you've
identified are valuable for there to be
or like that could be the north star
that you're going
after here more
thank you
[Music]
s
same
let go
[Music]
J
yeah we
should there we go
[Music]
and I think s like
is
[Music]
yes
the
[Music]
we have one more
minute so please start Gathering your
ideas
and choose what the north north star is
going to be for your pro for your round
we're done and we're up to the next
prompt so now you've already defined
what is going to be the North Star for
your um for your community or your
ecosystem and the thing that you're
going to have in mind as you're
designing the rest of the step of the
rer round next is we're going to
identify who are the audiences that are
involved in this richer rounds uh who
are one the projects or people that you
expect to fund through this round it's
going to be either the projects that are
applying or if you're not asking them to
apply you already have a way in which
you identify who's going to be legible
to participate in this round who are
they what do they look like are they
individuals are they
groups second as I mentioned before most
of the Retro rounds as we've seen them
is people vote on who gets allocated the
funds so who are going to be your voters
is it going to be everyone that belongs
to the community is it going to be a
selected group of people that are veryy
and have a lot of high context into your
ecosystem and
third is you're also going to identify
who is benefiting from this overall
impact that the people that you're
funding or the projects that you're
funding are generating like who are the
end users or end receivers of the impact
that is being
generated and map out who these
audiences are so that you can understand
what are their incentives what are the
trying to achieve whether it is within
your ecosystem or within your community
but what is the what moves them forward
and what are they trying to achieve so
that you can then continue to design
something that will ensure that you're
aligning their incentives with the
incentives that you're trying to achieve
through this round and here there are
some questions to guide you through
thinking through this the first one is
um
oops this
is
not
okay so apparently that the slide is
wrong but here it is uh as I mentioned
before identifying who is the audience
in terms of who are benefiting from the
impact that's been generated who are the
people that would be voting in your
round and who are the projects or people
that would be receiving funding through
this
round and for this we are going to give
minutes let's
start e
[Music]
you
that for
[Music]
h
back
[Music]
o
a for
[Music]
yeah for
and the time is up for this next
prompt and we're going to move to
the next prompt in which we are going to
be looking at setting behaviors and
defining what this behaviors are so what
we are as I had mentioned before in
these retro rounds what we're doing is
we're incentivizing very specific
behaviors that we want to see that we
have a loose idea that are going to take
us to this Northstar that are going to
enable us to get to these goals so for
this next prompt uh what you're going to
be doing is you're going to be thinking
about what are the type of behaviors
that you want to see the type of
benefits the type of
recognition um that you want people to
have or you think people will uh
appreciate from participating in this
type of actions that are going to get
you closer to the North Star so think
also about what are some of the
Milestones that are in between where you
are right now and getting to the North
Star so that you can identify what are
the type of behaviors that I'm trying to
inside for people to do that are going
to get me closer if you're looking at an
ecosystem round maybe this behavior is
contributing to the open source code
maybe this Behavior looks like
deploying uh smart contracts and
attracting new users into my ecosystem
if we're thinking of a local round if
one of the things that you're
incentivizing or you value the most is
say um protecting the forest maybe the
type of behavior that you're looking for
is planting trees or protecting trees
that are already in a specific Place uh
taking care of the
trees these are the type of behaviors
that you might want to
incentivize that people have or do as
you're going through and that is going
to be rewarded at the end of the round
so we're actually going to give uh I
know it says 12 minutes but we're only
going to give 8 minutes for this part as
well and you can start
now and try to be as specific as
possible when you're thinking of the
behaviors that people are going to
have um because this part is going to
help us to identify what what is the
data and what are the metrics that we
can use to measure the type of behaviors
that people have already completed and
that we could reward in the round so
again sort of like if we are looking to
protect the like if it's a local
community and what they want is to
preserve a particular area then maybe
we're going to be looking at planting
trees or having a more healthy ecosystem
and then how do we Define what a healthy
ecosystem looks like like is it the
number of trees that are in a specific
space is it the type of behavior that
people are having when going
around so this is what we're going to be
looking at
[Music]
what
find
[Music]
is
h
[Music]
than
m
[Music]
High h
this is the
[Music]
speech
speech spee spee
[Music]
okay we have one more minute before we
go to the last prompt
okay we're going to move on to the last
prompt since both uh since the groups
are already done with this
prompt and as I mention to both of the
teams the way in which you're designing
your round is going to inform the
evaluation process that voters are going
to be able to complete when you are uh
giving them information to decide who
should the funds be allocated to and
it's also going to inform the type of
data that you're able to already extract
from existing sources or that you need
to create hope like the best thing there
is to create it in a standardized way so
that people can cross-compare it among
different amongst different
projects so for the last prompt we're
going to be looking at data and metrics
for this evaluation and there's two
actions here that you're going to be
looking
into or questions that you can use to
guide your process through the first one
is now you know based on the behaviors
that you want to see happen from these
different audiences what you're aiming
for and what are the potential actions
that the members or people or projects
can undertake to get to the North Star
how can you measure these actions like
over here we were talking about oh we
want to have more developers building in
this particular ecosystem and we talked
about developing looking
like launching their own smart contracts
it could look like contributions into
the uh gith hubs and into the repos from
the different um libraries or tools that
are relevant to the
ecosystem then you can also
explore are there already existing data
sources for this information and if
there are not existing data sources for
it how can we measure this in a
standardized
way and we're going to give 3 minutes
for that and then we'll start wrapping
up
yeah because we have e
[Music]
you
you for
[Music]
is it is it moving forward we have one
more minute
left okay so we were talking about uh
how do we value like builders in terms
of measure the quality or the impact of
the
C and and I was using some examples when
in the on rounds or like the GitHub
commit stuff like that and we talking
about maybe that's spam is not good and
maybe we should look at the quality of
the codes and I were like how do you
even standardize that is it all right
very subjetive it's the same problem we
have in OB exactly no but it is
subjective I think the good thing though
is like how can we get
subjective um evaluations to become
like how do we push things to become as
most objective as possible uh and that
can look by like for example it's very
very subjective
maybe different um you have five
different things within the code that
you're reading and then that helps like
ruce theity of
it reviewing it to a degree yeah no
you're welcome perfect so we're coming
to the end and I think now what would be
really interesting this was the last
prompt and so as I mentioned this was a
taste of what the design phase looks
like when we're looking into mechanism
design the second there's several other
steps that would follow but right now we
only focused on the design space of the
problem and so we're going to just ask
real quick the two teams if you can
share what your round whom you were
designing this round for what is the
type of incentives that you wanted to
generate what was going to be rewarded
and who the audiences are we have very
limited time so if you can explain it in
like one minute or two that'd be
great
uh hello uh so our rual funding Dr is
for ecosystem uh specifically it's Unis
swab
ecosystem and uh the round we were
thinking about is the uh uh the hook
ground so uh the that they just released
so uh the goal would be to
uh increase the Builder that build on
the Unis swap hook ecosystem increase
the numbers of high quality hooks uh you
know or build hook tools people for for
for making it the easier for developers
to work on it and also like onboard
builders on the ecosystem
and uh some of the audience would
include web three Builders um uh
Educators who help and also the benefit
uh this will benefits like the uh web 3
developers univers oft uh Unis swap
users uh Unis swap token holders and uh
who will vote on this uh we're still
debating on this but we think probably
like uh the Unis swap token holders but
yeah uh
yes so the behavior we want to see is we
want uh that to build on the hooky EOS
system uh them to deploy uh the smart
contracts and also uh we want you know
some like Educators content creators to
create like uh content for HS to spread
like the information to help on by
people and also
uh yeah and and people to participate in
voting and stuff like that
y it's now perfect thank
you
and so please I know we're missing the
last group but I don't think we have
time for that anymore as we're two well
just make it really really brief we
still have two minutes but this is the
QR code for the group like please feel
free to join as well um and we can
continue exploring what these designs
look like
okay okay we design uh retro funding
retro funding for to incentivize more H
women developers H to on board to web
three and the the goals will be have
more women um contributing H to the webt
space incentivize more de BRS to create
or to have a workshop for this
specifically um audience and the
audience for or or funding will be the
that can be individuals and also
developer
communities and the behaviors that we
are looking for is first on boarding
more women with Workshop F focus on them
and also more women contributing to open
source
projects uh in the
milestone in the Milestone we have
increased women attendance by 25% in 6
months and 25% in 6 months and in grease
and then have more women meetups during
a year and okay thank you awesome thank
you so please feel free to share the
designs in the telegram group uh thanks
a lot um seal and I were really happy to
host this workshop and we're excited to
see more people approaching mechanism
design in a more uh methodological way
so that we can have better outcomes for
how we're allocating funding in the
space thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you for
[Music]
e
EXP
know
supposed to be connected
to how about now there we
go so transport layer security TLS is a
old protocol it's ubiquitous it's all
over the Internet basically everything
supports it if you're not using it you
probably should be um and the important
thing is is that yeah all all websites
already support it and uh so yeah
basically it's a a protocol between your
computer and a website that you're
connecting to it's using
cryptography so you can query uh data
from a website and uh know that you're
talking to the website you expect and
your Communications are protected but
one thing that it can't do for you is
you can't query data from a website and
then present it to another party there's
reasons for this that I won't really go
into but you can just know safely that
it's not possible to just take a TLS
transcript and send it to someone else
uh they won't know whether or not the
data is actually
authentic um but you know TLS there
there are signatures there there's
cryptography there and maybe we can plug
into it and somehow leverage it for what
we want to do which is to allow people
to privately prove data to a third
party I'm not sure if you've come across
this jargon before there's multiple
different terms multiple different
approaches for generally the same thing
npct TLS CK TLS web proofs TLS middle
boxes witness proxy they're all
essentially trying to do the same
thing uh We've implemented MPC TLS uh
and this leverages multiparty
computation and zero knowledge proofs in
order to allow approver to privately uh
disclose data to a verifier in aitous
Secure
way and then there's other approaches
like aoxy approach which kind of
switches up the the topology here which
puts the verifier in between theover and
the website but
um oh right what one uh thing to note
here is that both these approaches both
the MPC TLS approach and the ZK TLS
proxy mode whatever you want to call it
these are both designated verifier
protocols which means that uh it's
really between two parties and the only
party who really receives cryptographic
assurances is the verifier that's
actually running the protocol itself so
sorry for everyone that wants to do
things on chain this does not give you
trustless oracles but it does give you a
trustless offchain designated verifier
protocol and uh yeah all approaches kind
of all go towards the same affordances
which is that it allows you to basically
compose with any application if there is
data on the internet which is queriable
using TLS you can trustless compose with
it and with without asking for
permission so all servers are already
running TLS so you can basically take
our protocol wire it into your
application and now Pro uh users can
just prove arbitrary data to you in a
privacy preserving
Manner and just to uh yeah elaborate on
the Privacy part there user can query
data from from some arbitrary data
source and present it to your
application while redacting their
secrets such as their uh cookies and
their HTP request they can redact data
in the response and uh we're probably
not going to get into it today but you
can also do zero knowledge proofs over
the top of that data such as hiding your
address but proving you know you're not
in the United States and then the
classic example of proving that you're
above some age without revealing your
exact birth
date yeah so those are the general
affordances that uh these protocols
provide uh TLS notary is free open
source uh the core protocol is written
in Rust we have typescript windings um
we're going to demo a browser extension
SL plugin system which is just one way
of Distributing the TLs notor protocol
and uh yeah it's Apache MIT dual license
at your option do what whatever you want
with
it yeah so that's an introduction to
generally what your list notary is and
what it does and yeah let's just hop
straight into into building something
so uh good afternoon I'm Henrik also
from the TS not team and uh this is our
schedule for the workshop today um we
are plenty of members of the TS notary
team so if you have questions there's
stanner Ryan uh who else do I see uh
Thomas in the back Chris and then Zino
and senu so just if you run into any
questions uh just ask so we'll we just
had this uh great introduction to TS
notary we'll start with uh coding part
one so that will be mainly on your own
machine uh everything offline so that we
don't run into any uh network problems
uh then we'll do some uh experiments
with TS notary where you work together
with your neighbor so uh just distribute
the roles
um and then we're ALS we we uh switch to
the browser
extension where we do will do a demo
first and then toino will give an
overview of how the all browser setup
works then we'll switch to coding part
two where we'll uh build our own plugins
and then we'll do a short uh an extra
slide with uh some uh uh where we go
into the future of TS notary and discuss
what comes up next and then there's uh
some playtime where we invite you to
build your own plugins or build on top
of TS notary and we're here to help you
and then we also are very open to hear
uh all your
questions
so um some tips and tricks for the
workshop so don't rush through all the
items uh we have time um there is a um a
MD
documents it allows for adding comments
so if you run into any uh into things
that don't make sense or you see typos
or whatever just comment so that we can
improve it for next time uh also check
the Wi-Fi so there is a local Wi-Fi
network here uh that allows us to
connect to each other so make sure
you're on the uh yeah I can't read the
name but I think it's the classroom
network uh the network uh the password
is also over there uh also for the web
devs that uh will do a little bit of
rust but it's only reading rust code so
don't be intimidated uh that you should
be fine and also as I said the TS noty
team is here so if you have questions uh
just ask
them so um if you go to this URL you
will find the uh classroom notes and
yeah if you have uh any issues just uh
call us and then we will
help so maybe a quick overview of what
we will do there so we will start with
the most basic setup of TS notary where
we just have a server approver and a
verifier where everything is on the same
uh networks on your local computer so
we'll start
with uh starting all the um the
necessary
services and then the approver will do
the request to the web server with the
corporation of the verifier this will
return in an attestation we will do then
do create a presentation where we redact
some information and then the verifier
will verify the info and then the second
part we will work with a neutral uh
notary so where the roles of the
verifying parts are uh split up so this
is all in Rust and then in the third
part of the example we will run the
approver in the browser um and then in
the notes you will see that then we will
also distribute the roles so you could
run the approver and your neighbor could
be the test server and another neighbor
could be the the verifier um should be
fun
any questions so
far so the question was which repository
for the first item so that's the tlsn
Repository
uh sorry so if you didn't bring your
laptop this will be a very boring
Workshop I'm afraid um so maybe then
just chat with uh some of us and ask us
your
questions
e e
[Music]
oh
I
[Music]
I haven't talk about any any stuff stuff
must
if you have an error message running the
last command command don't stress that's
for further in the workshop so the
prerequisites is mainly uh to have all
the dependencies on your uh laptop um so
that you can go through the the
following steps
I accident
[Music]
St so something
you for
[Music]
a
if you run into a rust C error check
your car uh your rust compiler version
and then just to rust up update to uh
get the latest rust compiler
[Music]
not
J
[Music]
f
yeah
[Music]
e
e e
[Music]
this
thir
[Music]
oh
back
e e
so they couldn't install the
PK for
[Music]
for
e for
[Music]
know
for
[Music]
e
for for
[Music]
yeah
e for
[Music]
is
so
[Music]
that's
for for
[Music]
play e
some
[Music]
for
e for
[Music]
h for
this
[Music]
oh
come e
[Music]
so how are we doing is did everybody get
through the solo tasks are there already
teams doing uh
notori maybe hands like one hand is solo
two hands is
steams okay I'll give you more
time real quick if you running anyone
with the so we had a few people three so
far only that have had issues with X and
GF yeah we couldn't figure out what it
was what so XM GS is not installed we're
being
Reed we can't run the inst
okay so they're having to build it from
scratch or just turn a VPN
on okay well we'll do
that when he's yeah but yeah me and Tak
just spent like the last 20 minutes TR
to figure out why okay yeah cuz yeah
it's was like why is it every out fine
but then like three
people I thought it was something
missing in our scripts no something
something in there's a like the first
line of the install script is a API
really
I
e e
to for
[Music]
yeah for
you e
very
[Music]
TR
can I have your attention for a
second so if you we made a mistake in
the notes so if you get to testing the
browser
extension uh you do get an error me
message in the notary uh because so far
for the rest examples we were on the dev
Branch but the browser extension is
still on the stable version so before
you run um the browser extension switch
to the alpha 7 branch in the tlsn
repository and then restart the notary
but um in alpha 8 we added this feature
where you can disable TLS from the
comment line uh in uh in eight so in the
def version that is possible but on
seven not so you need to edit a config
file uh so go to not
server config config yaml and so set
this line uh to false before you start
the the
notary
okay e
you
can for
[Music]
to
St
[Music]
uh yeah
the
e
e e
uh we're getting a little bit behind
schedule so I'll give you five more
minutes and then we will switch to demo
mode and then I will show
um the uh connect API and then we'll do
uh the toos part
[Music]
this
e
[Music]
for for
where
[Music]
don't
I have
[Music]
half an
hour has his SL
so uh to save some time I will uh show
you what the web app demo looks like and
then afterwards toino will show you how
it actually works in the internals so we
have built this demo app for TS notary
where um we built this app where we ask
user to prove that he has a Twitter
profile then our backend checks that
attestation and then in the end we uh
reward the visitor uh with a PO app so
if you didn't go through it yet uh you
can do it later and earn your PO app so
it's we this app first invites you to
install the the um extension but I
already have it on my computer uh next
step is to install a plugin to the
extension to connect to the actual uh
Twitter
demo uh of course we don't want to just
install random plugins so we always ask
the user do you agree with uh installing
this into the TS notary extension and so
this also gives an indication of what
the plugin will do so it shows you that
it will uh run requests to the
proxy um access api. x.com and then it
will uh do requests to this URL so
there's nothing uh strange going on
behind the scenes uh and then of course
it also needs to acquire some more
information um now the plug-in is
installed when you do run plugin uh
again you you need permission to do it
uh and when you click it you go through
the steps but I think most of you
already went through this steps um so uh
if we switch back to this demo app then
now the app is also listening to whether
the attestation is uh
ready so yeah so once the attestation is
available the uh back end will then very
the proof and uh then as a reward you
can uh claim the PO app but toino do you
uh explain what was actually going on
here hi good
afternoon um so you saw a demo of the
browser extension and plugins um to kind
of give a brief overview of the
extension um what it is is it basically
cash all the headers and all the cookies
from your browsing history and then on
request it will you it will provide that
to the plug-in and um create this
notarizations um so you guys saw the
demo and um we created a connect API um
for the browser extensions um you can
check out the
documentations but on a fair high level
um it is the equivalent of the window.
etherum object but for TS notary so
similar to how metas another extension
um waterall extension inject a provider
to window um we also insert a um
provider to window. tosn and from there
you can use that to interact with the
extensions um and do
stuff so it's pretty simple to use it um
I'm going to walk through a a few um
like use case um when your app first
load you can listen to event called TSN
loaded and then once it's ready um
window. TSN will be ready and you can
grab that you can then call the connect
um function um it will pop up a um
permission window approval window asking
um for permission to connect to this
website and and once connected basically
they'll be able to um request for
notarizations and ask for notarization
history and stuff like that um after
that um this is if you like let's say if
you want to create a
um attestation for some website in this
case I'm using swappy dode as a example
um you can do it with the client object
that you just created um by connecting
to the extensions um s very similar to
how you make a fetch request with um
with some extra metadata um you can you
know create any
attestation for for this
API and once you create the attestation
you can also use get history to get like
the attestation that you just created um
so all this method is designed to help
app developer to easily interact with
the extension to create proof um RFI
proof and you know be able to do stuff
that you need to do um in your app
so um we also develop a plug-in system
um that allow you to um create a plugin
to prove whatever rep data you want
um when you prove a rep um data from a
rep API usually the flow goes
like um give me cookies of this website
and give me headers of this website I
will then use that information to um
piece together the request parameter and
then I will submit this request
parameter to the notary or to the
interactive verifier and then start the
notarization process um so all these
steps are
um uh you're able to do all these steps
in the plug-in systems um with the API
that we provided um I'm going to go
through really quickly how the what the
API looks like um you can also go to the
um documentation site down down below we
have a um boiler plate repository that
you can um check out to see how plugins
are written a lot of you already um have
already checked it
out the plug-in um center around this
like config do Json object um the main
idea is we don't want to just inject all
cook keys to any Plugin or headers any
plugin so you have to ask specifically
for permissions um in this case
the plugin is requesting for all cies
from api. x.com all headers from api.
x.com um we also enforce um what host
function you're asking for you need
permission for right now we only have
two host function one to redirect the
current browsing Tab and the other to
send a notary request um at some point
we'll probably have more um and then the
fourth permission here is the type of
request that a plugin can make
um basically we don't want the plugin to
be able to send any request to any host
like they could just send your cook key
to some host um that's why we put this
enforcement here you the plugin will
only be able to send a get request to
API dx.com blah blah
blah and after that you describe from in
the config what your plugin does title
description do a metadata the steps um
array here describe describe how many
steps this plugin will have and what
each step does um the action there
correspond to a function name that you
create in the
um in the plug-in code so for for
example the first step is called
start and here is a very simple stock
method basically it checks to see if
you're on x.com if not redirect to
x.com and then the second step is
basically getting cies from x.com
getting all the headers making sure you
have the require cies and headers and
then piece together the parameters that
you um that you need to make the notary
request and the the final step here is
sending it to the notary to make an
authorization request um there is a
another method that is uh referen here
called get secret response um basically
what that does is if you don't want to
reveal um everything to the notary you
can call this you can create this method
to selectively disclose what you want to
disclose to a notary in this case um I
am only disclosing my Twitter screen
name to the notary and nothing else no
cookies no headers um this will pause
the response and make sure that it's
only revealing what I want
and once it happen this is um what the
plug-in step a um UI look like in the
future we'll add more API to allow more
customization on the UI level but for
now um if you describe what the what
your steps look like it will be render
um in this manner go through step by
step and then at the end create the
notarization um I think
oh oh yeah and if you are trying to
compile or build a plugin um you might
want you might have already R into this
issue where
ext.js is not found um we forgot to put
um put that in the documentation but
basically xstm is what we use to build
the plugin system and in order to
install xterm.js you basically have you
just go to um xem sljs do js- pdk not
SDK pdk and then one the install script
there um after that you have exsm Js and
be able to build
scripts
cool anyone have questions
so compiling the plugins shouldn't take
long and then we switch to the part with
what's coming up next for TS not3
[Music]
look
okay if we're going to kind of speed
through the plug-in part here uh yeah
let's just talk about what's next for TS
notary um so alpha 8 coming soon I'm
surprised that not more people asked me
when Quicksilver and when a de
code um they're coming so quick silver
certainly an alpha 8 off decode that
depends uh Quicks Silvers have higher
priority it's essentially performance
Improvement so some of you might notice
that it takes you know multiple seconds
for this to run and to end uh quick
silver is going to be a pretty massive
performance Improvement and reduction of
communication between the approver and
verifier uh there's still lots of work
to do and this is one of them uh and
yeah we we'll be posting some benchmarks
with that with that release they should
be pretty nice uh yeah going into next
year uh there's a couple nice toab just
TS 1.3 support uh TS not right now only
Sports 1.2 uh for most people that
doesn't mean anything uh but TS 1.3 is
kind of like the most recent version of
TLS and 1.2 in the future may get
deprecated so we want to be ahead of
that but yeah the theme for 2025 is
going to be towards stabilization we
kind of want to finish if that's
possible the the the core Library the
core
implementation um work to get the
underlying uh MPC Library uh audited and
then start working up into the TS notary
stack and get different uh parts of the
code base audited um we're going to be
working on security proofs for the
different different uh for the various
different cryptographic instructions in
our protocol uh proofs already actually
kind of exist paddle Labs with their
garbled and proof paper actually covered
a lot of uh what we're doing but we kind
of want to replicate those results
ourselves and and and present them uh so
yeah 2025 is going to be uh well of
course after shipping the performance
improvements of quicksilver it's going
to just be like let's try to stop
changing things as much and just kind of
focus on getting it towards
stabilization so we can remove the for
uh research purposes only disclaimer on
the repository which is on like 99% of
crypto
projects um yeah so any just Q&A on uh
future TLS notary other than wi
Quicksilver and when off you
could raise your hand
your by server are you referring to
notary so the question is is our notary
fully
trustless
um so it depends on what exactly you're
talking about there so a notary is going
to be issuing an add a station to some
to the data right so the Prov is
connecting to the notary they're proving
information to the notary the notary is
putting a signature on it and saying I
ran this protocol correctly now when the
approver takes that add a station and
presents it to another party there is a
trust assumption there that that third
party verifier is essentially trusting
that the notary ran this protocol
correctly and that they didn't just
forge this attestation without doing
anything so in that sense there's trust
but is there trust between the prover
and the notary itself no uh so there's
nothing that the notary a malicious
notary can do in order to like for
example leak the user Secrets they don't
really see anything they're just signing
kind of like blind commitments to the
data itself so from a privacy
perspective no there's there's no trust
assumption now a lot of offchain
applications don't actually need a
notary a notary is really only needed if
you want to like maximum privacy this
party doesn't know anything and it's
just attesting to uh data that it
doesn't see um you could actually just
remove that step and the prover can just
selectively disclose directly to a
verifier that's willing to run the TLs
notary protocol and in that sense like
the whole protocol end to end and the
Integrity of the data is like quote
unquote trustless um like I mentioned in
in in the introduction the protocol is
designated verifier so a lot of people
want to build applications on chain and
uh in that configuration you're kind of
just stuck with this trusted third party
at at a station so like in short it
depends but in terms of security for the
user uh we we worked hard to make sure
that no there's no trust assumption
there it's it's cryptographic assurances
for the privacy of the
data can you repeat the question
perhap okay maybe I I'll try to rephrase
this can you construct or how do you I
guess minimize trust if using TLS notary
to construct an oracle protocol yeah
that's a good question uh there's a few
different folks that are looking into
this uh one of the issues is that again
the protocol is designated verifier so
you can't have multiple parties
attesting to the same connection so
approver will need to prove to I guess
each Oracle node independently and then
they'll all have to come to consensus on
some fact that the prover is trying to
prove uh as opposed to all essentially
just providing a signature on a single
transcript um there's a subtlety there
and that every time that you query the
server it's going to there the
transcript is going to be slightly
different somehow there'll be some sort
of entropy in it um so the question of
how to like construct a trust minimized
uh Oracle protocol is uh difficult the
the ideal solution is to make TLS notary
support multiple notaries in the NPC TLS
protocol the issue with that is that uh
there don't there aren't really any MPC
protocols that exist in which that would
be practical the compute and the and the
bandwidth costs of the protocol just
like blow up if you try to add
additional parties so we're kind of
stuck with this two-party setting um so
yeah trust minimization is really just
going to come down to can you construct
a clever consensus protocol with
multiple notaries and and you're really
just getting into like Oracle design and
things like that uh we're kind of
punting that problem to people uh that
are focused on Oracle protocols whereas
TS notary is kind of just a A Primitive
you can use to construct it um but yeah
it's an active area of research for many
people is how to take these ZK TLS um
libraries and and do that and and It's
Tricky more
questions so feel free to finish
the uh Workshop uh later at your own
pace if you run into any problems uh
just uh ask your questions on our
Discord uh there's only friendly people
there willing to
help and how do we switch
it just scan you register as a question
you can see the question okay we're
figuring out how to get to the questions
in the defcom
tool how's it compared with other TLS
protocols like Deco reclaim Etc uh
in subtle ways they're all essentially
trying to achieve the same thing which
is how do you get how do you modify TLS
in order to get um a protocol that
proves Integrity of data from some uh
some source so Deco I believe the
original paper actually describe both
the MPC approach and the proxy approach
uh I'm not sure where they're at with
implementation I think that they have a
proof of concept or or at least like a
sandboxed uh early release that they
just put out but I need to kind of
follow up and see what they're doing uh
in terms of implementation yeah I I
believe that uh Deco is doing the MPC
TLS approach as well but that might be
outdated information uh reclaim is also
um essentially doing the same thing as
you TLs but they're taking like this
proxy mode approach um there there are
privacy and security kind of trade offs
to consider there it would probably take
me a full presentation a full 30 maybe
40 minutes to go into all those
differences but in terms of
affordances uh they're all essentially
trying to do the same thing with various
different performance and privacy
tradeoffs that's kind of a Dodge of a of
an answer but that's the best I can do
right
now all right I think we can wrap it up
thanks for everyone
[Music]
o
w
[Music]
o oh
is
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
oh
he oh
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
m
oh e
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
oh